um
good evening everybody and welcome to
this evening's meeting of planning and
development management committee and
just by way of an introduction my name
is aiden williams and i'm the chair of
the committee also present this evening
is the committee vice chair councillor
ben hartley
offices from the council's planning
service legal and democratic services
the local highway authority as well as
the elected councillors who make up the
voting members of the committee
just before we continue i should advise
for everyone's attention that this
meeting has been live streamed and
recorded
and before considering the applications
for development i'll just give a brief
overview of the process for anybody
watching this evening there's a number
of planning applications which need to
be determined each application will
receive a brief introduction from an
officer at the council's planning
service and they will provide a
recommendation as to how the planning
service for your committee members
should vote there will then be the
opportunity for representations from
approved community groups
representatives and members of the
public
following this discussion will be held
by members of the planning committee
members will discuss the merits of each
application utilizing their local
knowledge
and in so doing they should explain
whether they are mounted to support or
oppose officer recommendation
when doing so they should explicitly
justify the decision by making clear
reference to planning grounds and
recognized planning policies and
frameworks members are free drawing the
discussion to ask officers for guidance
or clarification
members can then propose a motion to
support or refuse officer recommendation
if the motion is supported by a second
member a vote will be held in the
outcome determined by majority decision
turning to the agenda this evening item
one is attendances and we've received
apologies from councillors dagnole
and
akanola and morgan i don't believe that
we have received substitute members um
to in that place
item number two declarations of interest
the only members council walton
okay thank you for that um item number
three is minutes which have been
circulated along with the committee
papers
um members happy to support those as an
accurate representation bus
yep i'll take those as approved okay
thank you
um
it's number four is questions from
members of the public
we did receive some questions which um
were reviewed by democratic services and
it was felt that they weren't um
actually put into the business of this
committee so a member of the public
who's um
[Music]
sent those questions to the council has
been advised to direct them to
alternative
departments at the town hall
item number five is additional
information report that was circulated
via email earlier today to members there
are also paper copies available this
evening
and we'll now turn to item number six
which is applications for permission to
develop and the first application we'll
consider this evening is 103 844 london
stratford mall in stratford
which is on page one of the committee
report
before we
proceed further the item is going to be
introduced by mr pearson
thank you chairman um
the application before members relates
to the comprehensive mixed use
redevelopment of stratford mal
and land adjacent to lacey street on the
opposite side of the a56 you can see the
two areas of the application site on the
screen
the council's joint applicant together
with bruntwood as its joint venture
partner
a significant amount of pre-application
consultation has taken place with the
local community and other interested
parties in relation to these proposals
which has helped to inform the approach
taken to the development
it's a hybrid application um the full
element of the application is for the
demolition and you can see the buildings
that are to be demolished on the screen
there so a fairly sizable
area of the mail
and then
we have uh
in outline form
uh a proposed development
and that seeks outline consent for the
readable redevelopment of the site
comprising up to 800 residential units
both
townhouses and apartments
commercial business and service uses
public house and drinking establishment
uses
learning and non-learning institutions
and local community uses
the application includes a
maximum height parameters plan so you
can see the
proposed maximum heights here this this
will guide future reserve matters
applications detailed applications uh
which should not exceed the height shown
on on that plan
that has been revised slightly since it
first came in so heights on the
south of the screen um sorry the
screen's going around quicker than i'd
intended uh you can see up to three
stories there on the kind of southern
and western boundaries of the site that
was a revision too to the scheme
as was the height parameter along
kingsway on the on the north of the site
that's been reduced in height as well so
you can see that the height
the greatest height is censored in the
center of the site
so some elements that would be allowed
to go up to eight stories
but largely uh up to six stories
there's also an indicative phasing plan
and this is indicative but you can see
if you can read it
phases 1a
um
up around the the entrance to the male
from king street um and then
one see along uh the a56 one be the car
park those are thought to be the the
earliest um
phases of what would be the earliest
phases of the development
the proposal includes um substantial
amounts of open space including an area
that's going to be known as
watson gardens that's in the the center
of the site there the biggest great
green space that you see
as well as a large area of public realm
adjacent to the canal
in terms of access strategy um
the outlying consent is is permission is
sought for access
with all of the matters reserves and the
plan indicates a number of new or
relocated access points into the site
whilst parking would be accommodated
within the existing multi-story car park
as well as within selected locations and
other parts of the site
in terms of our assessment of the
application it's considered that the
scheme would have a transformative
impact on the town centre
enhancing it as a facility and
destination for local residents and
those visiting the area
whilst the detail layout scale and
appearance of the development are
reserved for future consideration
the submitted information demonstrates
that a high quality well-designed scheme
can be delivered which provides a good
standard of amenity and appropriate
parking and access facilities for future
residents and users of the site
proposals are considered to be in
accordance with the development plan
the national planning policy framework
and relevant local and national planning
guidance
given that the currents the council has
a current lack of a five-year
supply of immediately available housing
land the tilted balance
set out in the mppf is applicable
and in carrying out this exercise it has
been concluded that the adverse impacts
of granting planning permission
would not be significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the benefits of
doing so indeed the benefits of the c of
the scheme are considered to
significantly outweigh the adverse
impacts identified above
and these include the provision of 25
affordable housing on site
a significant financial contribution
towards improvements to education
facilities in the area
and significant benefits associated with
their transport transformative
regeneration of the town centre
the application is therefore recommended
for approval subject to the conditions
listed in the report and the completion
of a suitable legal agreement
a general members attention to the
additional information reports this
includes our heritage officer comments
set out in full which didn't appear in
the original report
additional there's one additional
representation and one additional
consulting response
minor alteration to paragraphs in the
main report on housing land supply
the clarification of the sports england
objection
a reduced contribution was considered to
be appropriate but this has not been
offered but nonetheless this doesn't
change the outcome of the planning
balance
uh there's also been one additional
tweak to a condition and one additional
condition added
thank you
thank you um we do have speakers
speaking both against and in favor of
the application and speaking against the
application is tony great with
um i understand we've received a
statement which will be read out by ms
lowe
from tony great rex of wellington street
stratford i would like to know what is
happening to wellington street and how
it will be affected including the
following points
is there access to new housing from
wellington street
if it is access only for refuse
collection
does this mean that refuse bins will be
placed on wellington street
how will the residents only parking on
wellington street be affected and what
is happening to the line of trees that
separate wellington street from the car
park
thank you um
speaking in favor of the application is
conor villally
hi mr villally thanks for joining us um
you have three minutes to speak if you
went over time i'll just politely ask
that you wrap up your contribution and
if you can just make sure that the
microphone's on
that'll be great thank you
thank you chair
good evening members my name is conor
valley from robertson young i'm the
planning agent for this application
i'd like to thank the officers for all
their hard work in producing a
comprehensive report
the regeneration of stratford town
center is long overdue
having been identified as a key council
objective in the adopted core strategy
the refresh stratfor master plan and the
merging area action plan for stratford
members will be aware from the officer's
report that before this planning
application was submitted
a very significant amount of community
consultation and stakeholder engagement
has been undertaken
including prior to covet 19 and and the
during the pandemic online
feedback has been carefully considered
and has helped shape and form the scheme
the officer's report with regard to
policy confirms
this development fully complies with the
development plan and meets objectives
including core strategy policy w-2
this identifies that appropriate
regeneration actions for strep for town
center could include widening the time
center offer securing new and improved
retail floor space new office
accommodation and family-oriented
activities
delivering new residential development
and improving the environment and public
realm
not only these transformational
proposals will be secured in terms of
policy but in addition to following key
benefits
regeneration of a sustainably located
site incorporating a mix of uses to
bring activity and vibrancy to a
reimagined stratfor town center
reinstating the historic king street and
opening the site up for better
pedestrian and cycle access
a major contribution towards the
five-year housing land supply as you
have heard
a major contribution towards affordable
housing of 25 percent on-site
education contributions of circa 3.7
million pounds
new inviting areas of open space new
parks simply squares
and the reactivation of the bridgewater
canal frontage with leisure uses
the scheme also deliver a high quality
design and much better connect stratfor
town center with the surrounding
community
it will also increase science center
employment opportunities including
spaces for smaller independent retailers
businesses and co-working
provision for community uses
and delivering low carbon buildings and
maximizing
active travel
in summary members this application
represents the first step of a
multi-phase project in transforming and
revitalizing the time center
allowing stretford to reach its full
potential
by creating a high quality
future-proofed environment which better
serves not only the existing community
but will also allow people to aspire to
live work and spend their leisure time
here
the applicant in conclusion which as you
know is a traffic brunt with joint
venture is committed to delivering an
exemplar scheme
and a view of the full compliance with
policy the lack of any technical
objections and the very significant
benefits which you've heard from mr
pearson
which will arise both for stratford and
impact on the wider borough we'd
respectfully request you endorse
recommendation for approval thank you
thank you mr villally um any members
wishing to open the discussion
no
i can kick off if people would prefer i
mean i i made this contribution as a
stretford town center resident and i
have to say
are you mr great tricks uh so i was told
that you would be uh providing a
statement do you want to speak to
committee
yeah yes yes of course sorry i didn't
realize that's a error on my part um
so similarly to the speaker before
you've got three minutes to speak mr
matrix if you do run over time i'll just
ask that you wrap up your contribution
thank you
cheers sorry
i've got a couple of things to say i'm
not wholly against this planet or
um obviously the mall needs something
uh doing with it
but i am actually one of the closest
residents to stratford mall
um
and that the parking
uh is of a big concern for me the
three-story houses
right in front of my property is of a
big concern to me um
parking i've never done this before so
excuse me not as good as him um
when we did the first consultations we
were promised that there would be no
access
to the mall site from wellington street
that was from mr hart's head and the
councillors yeah
i've just been given a drawing today
yeah
where
there is two
um
entrance points off church street and
wellington street
into the mult car park
this this this road is a one-way system
and it's
possibly one of the narrowest roads in
stratford you can only park on one side
half of us don't have drives
and and i find it quite
disturbing
and you all it's going to do
is create a rat run
for people to come off chester road and
hurtle down wellington street
um
there's adequate there is if you look on
google maps there is already a road
coming from
chester road
into the mall car park why can't that be
used
what why
why have we got to
put
more traffic on such a small
side road yeah
um there's children playing in the
streets
um
the lady on the end where you've got a
junction she she's actually lucky enough
to have a drive
she actually has to reverse out in the
morning now i imagine someone coming
around and it is a blind bend coming
around the blind bend there's an
accident
i don't think that particular area has
been been thought about properly
um
we did ask right at the beginning for
the the hedgerow to
um remain which i actually look after it
belongs to the mall but i look after it
because the mole
don't want to do it for whatever reason
um it's full of wildlife it's only two
meters deep but what it serves as is a
barrier from our house from our
properties
to
um
so whatever you're gonna build or
whatever building site we're gonna have
to look at for the next
five or six years or whatever longer
it's going to take
um i think that drawing
was not finalized
until the first of the third this month
i've never seen it till today
we we the actual residents of wellington
street and church street never had a
consultation on that drawing
we was never asked
do you want this did you not want it is
it okay
and i think really
that that needs to be done none of the
counselors have come to see us
and i think it's
the idea is okay but i think the impact
on
us as neighbors to that side is is not
going to be very good to be truthful you
know we've got pets we've got kids
you know we're used to the car park
we're used to the mall
you do what you want with that but you
just leave us alone
okay and you're having an overtime
script i think you get the gist of what
you're whatever
we'll reflect on that in the discussion
but thank you for joining us this
evening um okay thank you thank you very
much councilwoman stanley i think you're
indicated before you happen to speak uh
yeah i could but i'd like to have to
start with a question based on what the
gentleman has just said what is that
right that the
the map was not sent out until the 1st
of march
3 chairman um the plan that you see on
the screen at the moment is that the one
that mr gretrix was referring to yes
that that is a relatively new plan yes
but all that does is put together on one
piece of paper the access details that
have always been in the
in the application
well that's i mean that that's not my
understanding um
so
the greatest respect mr greater it's
it's not an interactive forum this uh i
don't want to
make you feel as though you've not had
you say but um and
perhaps if we
could also just reflect on the wider
comments that mr great explained around
the impacts on wellington street and i
know that the hedgerow is addressed in
the committee report but if we could
just make it a matter of public record
in this meeting that'd be great thank
you
yeah certainly chairman i mean um
i mean it's worth noting that the main
access is intended to be from kingsway
that's the
um
on the screen at top of the screen there
it's the right hand of those two arrows
that's the main access into the site
um
the the details that we have at the
moment suggest that it's likely to be
envisaged that there might be up to 30
parking spaces accessed from wellington
street but i think the thing we we have
to stress at the moment is that this
element of the scheme
is in outline form so we don't have
those details yet um
they will be subject to reserve matters
applications detailed applications
which will show us where the proposed
buildings will go
and
how they will be accessed
there's a condition attached to the
recommendation condition 22. um
which will require the the developer to
submit an access strategy with each
reserve matters application so for the
details
and that will need to demonstrate the
nature and use the frequency of how
those access points are intended to be
used
and and i'm saying all this and we are
very we're fully aware of the of the
nature of wellington straight at the
moment it's narrow we know that there
are houses close to it um
so
you know we we are fully aware of that
we're not quite sure
because it hasn't been designed yet
quite how that the land on the opposite
side of the road to the existing houses
will be developed that's down to detail
design work and everybody that will be
the subject of another application um
and residents will be consulted upon
that
um but as i say i can assure you that we
are
very much aware of of that relationship
it's very intimate relationship and you
know as officers we will be looking to
make sure that the
the amenity of existing residents uh is
retained as best as possible albeit of
course
things will change because there's new
development proposed
um
and the sort that access strategy um is
also
there is conditions to require that
existing parking spaces are retained as
well because there are some permit
holding
permit holder car parking spaces on on
wellington street
um
in terms of some of the other comments
made the hedgerow um
there's a tree survey submitted with the
application which does indicate that
some trees
may be failed on on wellington street at
either end but again it's all down to
the detail really and when we see
what the the detailed proposals are when
when that phase of the scheme comes
forward
those issues will be looked at then
but there will be
as a result of the proposal an awful lot
more tree planting on the wider site
than there is currently
um i think i think i've left any matters
out i think i think i've
covered most of the matters that were
raised
i i think so i don't know for them and
councilman stanley were you indicating
you wanted to say further
just to just um that's some reassurance
the resonant that this is not set in
stone yes this this is the
uh this is the outline planning
permission and an awful lot of the
detail have yet to be decided
so we've noticed lines on the map now
that will go out to further consultation
as we go to the next stages of the
of the process
yes yes that's right yes okay
all right thank you um
well before the intervention uh thank
you that's the to the resident
um
i was broadly in favor of this i think
stratfor miles had a stay i think that's
agreed by the residents
it was great 40 years ago but it's it's
time for something new
um i also agree i like the scheme
because it's time to tie
the other side of the a56 in with the
the rest of stratford that's also
something to be applauded
i also had the fact it's reinstating the
older more human um
structure of the uh the layout of the
streets around there i do understand the
the concerns of the locals and i hope
you're you're on the residence i hope
you are reassured that this this is not
as i say set in stone yet there's a lot
more work a lot more work to do
i was concerned about the heritage
assets but less than substantial harm
and i think outweighed by
800 houses
um
i do have one concern and it's really an
observation
rather than a concern about the
the plan as it now stands because
there's lots more consultation to do
i think
we can be more ambitious in what we're
going to do we're the joint developer in
this i think we could we could have had
more affordable housing maybe social
hand housing i also think it became more
ambitious in the um in the equality
aspect of this there's a very detailed
equality's impact assessments here
um several pages which is brilliant it's
it's great that we see those things now
but it feels as if it was done after the
event so the plans were laid up and then
it was looked at after the event it
would be brilliant if the
the
aims and administration are built in at
the the planning stage as opposed to
assessing plans against the later
administration
so i think broadly i mean i'm in favor
and um
i think i'll be voting in favor of the
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you um councillor chalking
thank you chair um yeah but i'm
very much in favor of this i've had the
fortune of walking around the site with
a director of place
we've been through the elements that are
going to go ahead um as well as the
future proposed plans um
it's quite exciting actually it's a it's
an area that needs a lot of investment
in it is going to look great um just
touching on the heritage council when
stanley pointed out uh
mentioned it's not mentioned in the
report so much but there is work to the
mile um that will restore the old
streetscape basically um
what the facades behind the the existing
storefronts are
still there
so it's it's it's going to look pretty
pretty good um my only reservation is
the future of the a56 um identify
identification of the site is is fine
but there is the a56 is going to be
restricted at some point whereas that is
the plans and i'm going to raise this
now because it's going to come up again
when we
talk about the future
buildings on the site
uh reducing
the road space is going to present a
problem trams are at capacity in peak
times already
um
adding another 800 units onto the site
or more less or more however many end up
being there is going to cause a problem
and it's going to come rear its head
again further down the line so i'm going
to make just once point out now
but overall i'm
in favor of the outline plan
and have to second that
thank you um councillor hassan
[Music]
thank you
uh before i give my few reservations i'm
totally agreed and it was a long waited
site needs to be developed in this area
north of the trafford
and in regards to the consultations
i myself was involved in the
consultations for the last couple of
years and
the majority of the
community groups came hundreds of people
came to stafford mall to give their
views on this
project so people are anxiously waiting
for this project so number one
uh it is uh my question to the officer
i heard about education facility what
does it mean to education facility in
there
can you please explain it and i want
more question again
i mean i can't understand it i'm fully
agreed because i was involved in this
conversation myself
uh
what kind of education facilities are
going to be provided in this project um
we'll be happy to
i'm sorry thank you
do you mean the education education
contributions
no no we
you just mentioned that
it will be a good addition into the
education facility
uh in into this project
i was i couldn't
understand properly i'm sorry
sorry i'm struggling to um that we you
use the word education facility i mean
what does it
mean i think what i'm assuming what
you're referring to is that
when um
new homes are proposed
um they invariably generate the demand
for new school places yeah and depending
upon the availability of existing school
places in that area
it might be that we ask developers to
contribute towards the provision of
additional school places
i'm assuming that's what you're what
you're referring to and this because
there are so many
new homes proposed in in in this scheme
and because
the existing schools are basically full
um there is in the region of a 1.8
million pound contribution for primary
school places and a 1.8 million pound
contribution for secondary school places
great that's required as part of the
section 106 legal agreement
and the second clarification very
quickly uh we are talking about the uh
parking issue and entrance issue that's
fine
uh
i couldn't hear about the uh pedestrian
crossing how many president crossing
coming from different
different uh streets from the barton
road or from the the residence hall just
mentioned we have any pedestrian
crossing going towards to the restaurant
stafford mall how many crossings are
there
i mean there will be a lot of new
pedestrian routes proposed within the
site yes um but then there are other
proposals outside this application for
for alterations to the existing highway
i think council chalking was talking
about it so both on king's way and the
a56 thank you
thank you very much
thank you councillor thomas
thank you chad just a few quick points
um
noted as just mentioned the
3.6 million pound education improvements
that has to be spent wisely because of
uh how full we are
a little disappointed it's only 25
affordable housing perhaps we're going
to look at that going forward but mainly
and it came through some of the
objections
it was a perfect opportunity to um
build in some cycle lanes on kingsway uh
to in
improve the infrastructure perhaps we
could take that on board going forward
and um
in light of the uh
person who spoke against him sorry i
can't remember your name
um
30 cars onto a car park
going in and out of that car park once a
day
massively changes wellington street and
church street from the road they are now
to an access road and
the road that is there at the moment
comes directly off chester road with a
filtered access and egress from
so perhaps we could there could be a way
around
using that going forward
other than that i think it's a fantastic
idea i think it will improve stratford
massively and although we're only at the
mind into grant stage of this and there
are a lot of developments forward i will
certainly be voting for it but
that there are concerns further down the
line
thank you um councillor hartley
doing a bit of time
thank you um
so the first one is around is around
landscaping which is addressed at
paragraph
130 which
uh on page 40 which talks about um
the submission of a detailed tree
retention and protection plan
to ensure the site is enhanced
and
the condition i think is condition 19.
the condition doesn't refer explicitly
to
an enhancement
i just wonder if that's if that's normal
the condition needs to refer to that or
is that something that
would be scrutinized as part of reserve
matters and
the landscaping plan will be scrutinized
to make sure there is an enhancement um
so that's one question i don't you want
me to
carry on or shall we
i've got more more questions yeah yeah
okay i'll carry on carry on um
i take on board what other members have
said about the affordable housing
contribution i mean i mean
i suppose my view on that is the
you know the viability case is
you know it's the same regardless of
whether the council is part of the
applicant or not so
um you know except 25 is is what's
viable but the condition um
[Music]
i wonder if we could amend the condition
the condition 15 at the moment specifies
20 25
and i i wasn't sure why it couldn't be
at least 25 so that if efforts could be
made to secure a bigger contribution to
affordable housing that
you know that will be permitted um at
the moment it's quite explicit sort of
shall provide 25
um sorry question third question is
around condition 46 which is about the
hours of operation for public houses and
drinking establishments
i just wondered if those hours were
right so it's 8 00 10 monday to thursday
8 11 friday and saturday
um
you know i i don't have any objection to
that but i know you know certainly at
the moment there are a number of
drinking establishments in that area and
i don't know what their
licensing arrangements are but um
you know i wonder if that if that was uh
correct and
permissive enough for the uses that are
proposed
um
final queries about the education
contribution which council thomas
mentioned 3.6 million which is obviously
welcome
um
i wondered if we could have some advice
on
how how that would work in terms of a
section 106 agreement so i appreciate
the applicant is
there's an llp so it's not the council
directly
um
but in essence the the council is
entering into an agreement
with itself to sort of pay half that
contribution i don't don't know if it
could be i guess what i'm looking for is
just some assurance around
how those monies will be secured and you
know they won't fall victim of
council budgets in the future
give them
shall we pause there
i think um mr pearson is in a position
to respond to the planning questions and
then legal services are going to reply
on the matter with the section 106
question yeah thank you thank you
chairman yeah so the first question
related to
landscaping and tree enhancement yeah i
i don't think we don't we normally do
use the word enhancement but i mean it's
i think it's a given that all new
development is required to provide some
landscaping it's accepted that you know
it brings a number of benefits
not least of all making places look nice
bringing biodiversity so i mean there
will be as i mentioned earlier i think
there will be a lot of new tree planting
within the site so it will be a much
greater place once developed than it is
now
um your second point related to
affordable housing i mean 25
is the required contributions so we
can't ask a developer to go beyond that
condition 46 the
yeah can i try and come back to you on
that one because i i know that those
hours um
yeah are not as late as you you would
anticipate uh so we'll just double check
the environmental protection um
uh response
and then i think
uh
ms coburn's gonna answer the last
question
yep in terms of the section 106 and you
quite right the council can't enter into
a legal agreement with itself and but in
this case um
the application um
and the
um owner
of the site
is the
joint venture and that is a separate
legal entity and so it is possible for
the council as lpa to enter into the
agreement with the joint venture
company
um
thank you i'm grateful for for that
further information it's really helpful
from officers thank you um just briefly
i mean i am um it's sort of subject to
those sort of queries i am really happy
with the proposal i think it i think
it's a good scheme overall i think the
benefits do play out where the albus
impacts i think it'd be a it's a welcome
regeneration of stratford which at the
moment
doesn't feel like it has a sense of
place it doesn't feel like it has a turn
center it's just sort of the mall really
so i really i really welcome that and i
think this will be a vast improvement uh
really welcome the
there's a lot of immunity space in there
on the indicative plan which uh you know
which i hope's delivered um i've
mentioned affordable housing
i like the idea of being a car free
development um and aiming for low
um
low rates of car ownership i think i
think that's a good aim it's a
sustainable location i do agree with
councillor thomas actually that i think
there needs to be um
consideration to walking in cycling
facilities
not just within the site but around the
site as well on on the a56 and on and on
kingsway you know
people aren't just gonna cycle around
the site you want people to get on their
bike and go elsewhere and come back um
and and i do think that is neglected on
a lot of applications that we see
there's an opportunity there you know
this is going to be 800 new homes
i think it's reasonable to have an
improvement to those facilities around
the site that are clearly going to be
impacted
um
the lack of the
contribution to sports facilities
you know is regrettable i think that is
an adverse impact i don't think it
changes the conclusion but um
there's a difference between open space
on the development and actual sports
provision and
trafford is poor for that it has a two
lower number of of playing pitches so i
would like to have seen that
contribution but um
be that as it may um
the final
the final sort of con well i suppose one
of the concern some of the concerns were
expressed by the heritage development
officer in the additional information
report and i think
it would be good for the developer to
take on board those comments and to try
and ensure that those views of the
heritage assets are are preserved i
think i think the indicative plan goes
a long way towards that particularly
around st matthew's church but i do
think
the developer should consider that
further for the reserve matters stage
i also think the
um
one of the other members did mention the
height of the development i can't
remember who it was forgive me but i do
i do think
that does need to be considered that's
probably one of my main reservations is
about the proposed height of some parts
of the development and a lot of that is
concentrated towards
the a56 which i can understand because
it's then not overlooking
um it's not overlooking other residents
and uses but it will sort of create a
bit of a a canyon effect and i i just
sort of think that will be
um
quite an unpleasant effect in some ways
um
you can see that other parts of the a56
and i think um i mean i have a different
view to cancel the chalk and i think
about the a56
the 856 is is still going to be a
problem unless there is some
change to it and it and it divides this
site in two so
for me at the moment that uh at the
stretford mall site and the lacey street
site
despite the efforts that have gone into
the application they're gonna feel very
partitioned and that's a major problem
for
for stratfor going forward as a place
you know despite this development but
yeah overall really welcome the plans
and happy to support the approval thank
you
thank you and councillor minis
thank you um i've got
i've got a couple of i mean i like
obviously the site needs to be developed
and i've no
issue with that um i have an issue with
the the blind bend um because
it's from that i mean it wasn't really
it's not extremely clear but on that
picture that you had
there are two bits into wellington is
that right
there are two accesses in the one at the
bend
and one further up now the one further
up i'm less less concerned with but the
one up the bend
they're gonna put one there that's what
i mean sorry yeah the i know i'm aware
there's not one there at the moment but
the plan is to put one there is that is
that something that's not set in stone
yet
i mean
that that's a planned
you know
the the applicant is applying for
approval for
access as part of this application oh
okay and those those are the access
points but what it was indicating is
that ultimately
it will depend upon the nature and the
layout of the proposed development the
details where the buildings are going to
go
just
where the accesses will be required
and and what they are likely to serve so
there's a main access point on off
kingsway that will take
most of the traffic for for the whole
site
but then there will be development on
that on that southern edge
and
access to that you know will need to be
considered and looked at but as i
indicated earlier you know we're very
mindful
of the nature and the character of
wellington street at the road it's at
the moment it's quite an intimate street
and the relationship of the houses to it
so as part of any discussions over
reserve matters applications we'll be
looking very carefully to make sure that
the amenity of residents isn't adversely
affected by by any access proposals it's
not it's less it's less for this part of
it there's less immunity of the
residents it's more and
the safety
and i just think putting having a
juncture onto a corner like that is is
it's just waiting for an accident to
happen
and i think it's dangerous that's that's
my concern it's not the case it doesn't
look pretty or not i don't know
look pretty or not isn't as a beholder
i'm saying it's a dangerous thing to do
i i don't i think the one further to the
left i i'm less concerned that i think
you know might not be my cup of tea but
that's a that's a different argument but
i think the dangerous one i i don't
think that's an okay thing to be doing
and if that is effectively
part of the application that the
principle of having it there then i
can't approve something that i know will
will be dangerous
i think that's that's that's
made a decision for me the other
question i was going to have but i guess
it's kind of like by the by now is in in
this development we have there's
obviously it's mixed use building
so we have um you know we have obviously
businesses commercial things all yeah
all sorts of parts and obviously
that's the right sort of site to have it
we have obviously local community uses
we'll have learning institutions and
i'm kind of half aware of
of of part of
of trafford's um
you know learning part that's going to
be that is planning to go into there so
and i'm aware of
the amount of cars that go to drop off
children to things is there going to be
a drop off is this going to be thought
about to
drop children to and pick up children
because many people do still go by car
to drop children to traffic music
service
so i'm just i you know i do i drop my
child i'm
believing that that's going there is
that not right
no not at all
okay i thought it was going here
it's going in a different building in
stratford as far as i'm aware okay okay
thank god for that but is it not going
to have is it not going to have the
issues that
that sort of thing would have if you
have
learning things
that's i mean the main thing to me is is
the is the blind bend and
and having an access there and if that
is part of the application then i can't
support it it's not it's not right
okay thank you for your comments council
council winston that you indicated you'd
like to speak yeah i'd be really brief
jay i promise i just wanted to return to
the
point about
um affordable housing just take that as
an example i wasn't talking about
compelling developers to
do more than they're required to do by
law i'm talking about using the power we
have as the joint venture companies have
the conversations with the developer to
perhaps get more than as required by law
those conversations can certainly take
place the team in front of me are going
to spend the next five years in meeting
rooms with
that gentleman there and representatives
the company these conversations can
certainly take place it's not about
compunction it's about soft power of the
council
to deliver the aims of the
administration thank you chair okay
thank you can i just clarify were you
happy before to propose that this if i
happen to take that as proposed by
councilman stanley and seconded by
councillor chalking um i i shan't speak
at lunch on this application myself but
i have to say i really really welcome um
this application and the the joint
venture
the the fact of the matter is stratfor
town centre's redevelopment is extremely
long overdue um the division that was
thrown up in the middle of last century
no longer really
suits a 21st century town center like
stratford and the report points that out
it's been clear for quite some time that
the um arndale itself needs shrinking
given that 25 of the floor space is
currently vacant
and i welcome the fact that the for
stratford town centre is now one of
mixed uses rather than just one large
shopping center um with a slightly dated
retail offer i welcome the fact that
there's an ambitious attempt to under a
i think a grand vision for lacey street
and paragraph 20 of the report provides
a really good overview of that um that
um
ambition to open up the canal side is
one that's already been realized further
down bridgewater in sale and i see no
reason why it can't be achieved in
stratford council hartley is corrupt
about
the impact of the a56 but i don't think
it's beyond uh the will of man to try
and find an intelligent way to get
through the fact that the town center is
currently something of a
divided area
um i welcome the fact that
we're making a sustainable regeneration
of the town center and we're doing so in
a way that's going to make it more
accessible as a town centre location to
our residents i know that other members
have spoken about the affordable housing
contribution and i take on board
everything you've said but the fact of
the matter is as far as i'm concerned
there'll be 800 units residential units
delivered on this site 25 of 800 is it's
a sizeable number and i think we should
really celebrate that
um so with that i'd just like to say
that
i welcome this application i think the
community welcome the application it's
only been a handful
of objections and i'm very happy to
support um
what we have before us this evening
and i'm pleased the fact that the
council has done in my opinion quite a
good job of consultation with the
community and having said that mr
greatrix i take on board all of your
comments and i hope that you can work in
dialogue um with the council as
quite what is quite protracted planning
process um continues and if you need any
help
with that those conversations being
facilitated
please approach me or
we can sort that i hope you i hope you
feel that you've been listening to this
evening um so are there any other
members who haven't spoken
looking to speed this evening
no mr pearson you indicated anything you
needed to add yeah i just conscious that
i've not come back to council hartley on
um
condition
46
um
and i think
thank you for for picking that up
councillor hartley because um
i think i've i've figured out what's
happened here we we had initially two
separate conditions
covering the opening hours of
public houses and cafes and we've uh
we've merged them into one following a
discussion with the applicant
and i think the intent of the initial
original conditions has been lost
so um
what i'm going to suggest is that
um
the opening hours
should be 8 until 11 at night monday to
thursday 8 until midnight friday
saturday
and then 10 till 11 sundays and bank
holidays
now the one there's one part of the
condition the final part of it um which
i'm wondering if the committee would be
happy to delegate to their head of
planning and that's the the time at
which any outdoor furniture chairs are
brought inside
at night because environmental
protection colleagues
um
are often concerned about the movement
of furniture because it can be noisy and
it can disturb residents and obviously
where we look at a mixed-use community
here where there'll be residents living
close to to bars
so
if if the committee are happy with that
that would be great
thank you i'm happy with that council
yeah happy for that to be delegated
thank you for um clarifying that point
it's a
important condition and if we got that
wrong i'd be most aggrieved on a
personal basis
um okay so it has been proposed in
second in the we support the office of
recommendation to grant permission for
this development i'll turn to the vote
now with members happy to support that
motion can indicate
thank you those not happy to support
thank you
yeah understood thank you
um okay that application is approved
um we're now turned to application 104 8
double one city point two point and two
hornby road in stratford which can be
found on page 73 of the committee report
this application is going to be
introduced by mslos
okay
thank you chair
and this application relates to um city
point
701 chester road and number two hornby
road
the application relates to a site at the
junction of chester road and warwick
road currently comprising a six-story
office building with surface level
parking beneath accessed off hornby
roads to the south
the character there is mixed comprising
of residential retail food and drink
office light industrial and sporting
venues
members may remember this site as it's
approved it's the site of a previously
refused planning application for a hotel
which was appealed and the appeal was
dismissed the current proposal seeks as
similar
similarly seeks permission for a hotel
but one of a reduced scale designed to
address the reasons for refusal and
issues raised within the dismissed
appeal decision
the application site is located with the
lancash lancashire county cricket club
strategic location
and is part of the draft civic quarter
aap within the western neighbourhood
highlighted as a gateway location
and suitable for development up to 12
stories in height
the site and the adjoining commercial
site along chester road frontage to the
west have been identified in the draft
aap as appropriate for mixed-use
development
officers consider
considering the determination of this
application that the aap has moderate
weight
now this application seeks permission
for the demolition of the existing
building and the erection of 169 bedroom
hotel with vehicular access off flummy
road in its current location and access
to 22 car parking spaces along with
public realm improvements along warwick
road and on to the chester road frontage
number two hornby road now performs part
of the application site and this is a
significant change since the previous
application and it's proposed that this
would be used as staff accommodation we
can see this here on the site
planning
[Music]
the previous scheme was a hotel um of
between 2 and 16 stories in height and
it's this image here on on the slide
this was refused by the council for four
reasons relating to design the impact on
the setting of nearby heritage the
impact on residential amenity and the
lack of car parking
the application was the subject of an
appeal with the inspector concluding
that the design and the impact on the
character and appearance of the area and
the impact on the setting of the listed
building were acceptable but it was
dismissed
and due to the impact on living
conditions to the residents on hornby
road mainly number two and the highway
safety impacts from lack of parking
including the lack of accessible parking
spaces
there has been significant evolution in
this scheme since that time to reduce
the scale and develop the detail of the
development the height has been reduced
from 16 stories to a maximum equivalent
of 12 stories
it's increased on-site parking to 22
spaces three of which are accessible and
issues of layout massing elevational
detail and the impact on adjacent
occupiers through the inclusion of
number two hornby road within the
application site are thought to have
addressed these concerns
so the height of the proposed scheme as
you can see on the elevation before is
stepped and we have a four-story element
that would front onto hornby road and
warwick road stepping up to a maximum of
10 stories with a screened
plant area and then on the corner we
have the tower um with this brick
crown brick frame crown sitting on top
which is the equivalent of 12 stories
and the top story here is a rooftop
restaurant and bar and the darker blue
here is a screened plant
and as you can see from the plans
there's quite a lot of detail in in the
um elevations and that has been worked
up in collaboration with officers
so as you can see on this elevation it
shows the building in three separate
parts within an attempt to break up the
mass this is the um elevation on
fronting onto aimchester road again with
this kind of brick frame creating a
crown at the top of the tower
and this is the rear elevation in which
would mainly be screened due to the
location of surrounding
existing buildings
this elevation is how it would be viewed
from hornby road and from the immediate
vicinity on on warwick road
the detailed design of the development
is considered to be high quality and
seeks to create local distinctiveness
this is through the inclusion of some
brick detailing on the four-story
element facing road which is to
replicate the appearance of stitched
leather of sports equipment or the mesh
of cricket nets as a nod to the sporting
history of the area
and along with deep recessed windows
bronze perforated panels rooftop
planting and public realm improvements
this is considered to add to the high
quality design of the proposal and to
create a landmark within the area these
details will be appreciated at street
level with the extensive area of active
frontage along the warrick road and
chester road frontages which we consider
will activate the street
the inclusion of number two hornby road
along with the reduced mass and scale is
considered to limit the impact on the
outlook and visual intrusion from the
remaining residential properties on
hornby road and is considered to address
the reasons
and concerns raised by the inspector
this just shows the
the public realm improvements and the
detailing on chester road
parking within the development has been
increased to 22 spaces and will be
managed through a parking valley system
which will be secured through a
condition which would require a parking
management strategy three spaces are
proposed to be accessible and whilst
parking does not provide the maximum
levels required by the spd3 it is
considered that the sufficient
save the development giving the level of
parking within the wider civic water
area to manage any impacts on
local street parking in the immediate
area it is cons
it is proposed to secure a contribution
towards the review of the existing tro
and residential parking restrictions
overall and we consider that the
development has evolved sufficiently and
has addressed the previous reasons for
refusal and issues raised by the
inspector
the proposal has been found acceptable
where appropriate
mitigation has been secured by will be
would be secured by planning condition
and legal agreement the proposal
complies with the development plan and
the mppf and the application is
recommended for approval thank you chair
thank you um
there's two speakers speaking to this
application and speaking against the
application is david rawlinson
hi mr rollinson thank you for joining us
this evening um you've got three minutes
to speak to committee if you do run over
time i'll just politely ask that you
draw your contribution to an end and if
you before you speak just make sure that
the microphone's on in front of you
thank you can you hear me yeah
okay
thank you for listening to me and giving
me the opportunity to speak
um
this
as the appeals inspector noted will
still be affecting occupiers of adjacent
properties by reason of overbearing
overshadowing overlooking visual
intrusion noise and or disturbance on a
further set order or in any way
the plan even says
due to the height of the proposal the
scheme will be seen from all surrounded
streets
and he also says being 13 stories in
height
that was taken
from their plans
also there are plenty of hotels with
easier access and positioned further
away from residential housing
and it's not much needed
some of the um
[Music]
things that refer to are going back to
2015 and are well out of date
i consider this disrespect previous
rejections by residents
counsellors and even the appeals
inspector and i find it difficult to
believe that anyone could see number two
being described as residential
with a pedestrian path alongside the
side and back door and the rear garden
to be used for two disabled spaces and a
turning space for vehicles
we use this fairly flowery language i
refer to breathing space
this is better described as a busy
traffic area in use 24 7
with the pedestrian path giving a
certain element of excitement for
pedestrians
and further it says mirroring the corner
position referring to the town hall
sites
so distorted the mirror
repeated changes to the plans with
little in the way of showing what has
changed
residents have other things to do
raising the supporting children
looking for the quiet life
jobs
and keep coming back
you said beauties and however they are
beholden and to me
and the residents it's a sore room
and not wanted nor needed
there's a statement by the lcc
and the traffic report
and it covers some good aspects but i
noticed that community news
have not put forward any statement and
they must have talked to many residents
who showed previous
objections
there's no details of the construction
phase or how
access and egress for large coach
parties are to be catered for outside
match day peak flows
i'll just point out that the last match
we had
we started at 12
30.
and they closed off
the road at 9 10.
it's in less than three minutes
thank you thank you for joining us it um
speaking in favor of the application is
brian match
so thank you for joining us this evening
and similarly to the previous speaker
you've got three minutes to speak and if
you can just uh make sure that the
microphone's still on i appreciate
thank you chair
this application is our response as
you've noted to the previous appeal
which raised only two issues one was
parking the other was scale and impact
of the buildings we've worked with your
officers for the past 12 months to meet
to achieve a scheme
meeting your aspirations expressed in
the plan
we now propose a 160
bedroom state-of-the-art hotel to
support the old trafford economy
seven days a week
so if i turn to the appeal there's two
issues i'll start with parking
firstly the site is in close proximity
to train and tram stations
a highly sustainable location which the
planning of the inspector report said
would lend itself to a substantively
lower parking provision than the maximum
standards
the way we've addressed parking is
through a valet system this is often
used in historic towns where they don't
want a lot of parking and basically you
if they
a concierge takes your car from you and
parks it this valet system would allow
guests to to check the availability of
parking in
real time through an online booking
system and it's a tried and tested
system in the hotel core in particular
and the hotel market has the benefit of
preventing guests turning up in a car
and unexpectedly having to find
alternative parking in the vicinity
indeed we do we don't expect that many
guests will come by public transport due
to the accessibility of the site
hotel is served by a 20-year 24-hour
management team who can respond to live
issues including complaints raised by
residents
there are existing parking controls in
the area and we've agreed to fund the
review of these to make sure they remain
effective addressing any parking
concerns
so if i turn to the design and impact
the bill that the proposal will remove a
building which you can as a council have
identified as having a negative impact
and the replacement will be more
sustainable a better design building
which makes a positive positive
contribution to the public realm
the step design has enabled us to reduce
the height of the building from that
existing on the corner on the corner of
hornby road from seven seven six stroke
seven stories to four
the taller corner feature
on chester road
produces a focal point at the
intersection which is a published
council objective
the form of the building is sculpted
around the needs of each elevation
the increase in active frontage
the elements such as all real windows to
prevent overlooking the setback of
higher floors and glass glass top floors
softens these elevational treatments and
with high quality materials proposed
adds interest and depth to each facade
the redevelopment of the site will help
to regenerate this area of great the
greater manchester
that is in need of investment and bring
public benefits which officers have
listed in paragraphs 257 and 259 of
their report thank you for listening to
me
thank you very much mr munch
any members looking to open discussions
councillor thomas
thank you chair um
i don't see
really that this this application is any
different
in terms of matching
um closed box image of residential
properties
from the last one i appreciate that
they've stepped it
but it still will affect and be plainly
visible from the rear gardens of army
road
not to mention
the traffic
parking uh which was upheld by the
inspector at the time
there are 169 bedrooms in this hotel
with 22 park car parking spaces of which
only three are accessible by car parking
spaces which is not enough
nowhere near enough the access to the
car park is on hornwood road which is
residential called attack so the impact
on the amenity of residents on hornby
road will be massively affected
massively
notwithstanding that the 22 car parking
space are we told to support 40 staff
full-time staff
of which
i would assume most would be in during
the day
um
the 169 visitors going to the hotel for
the bedrooms
of which not all of them i would doubt
that 50 of them would come by metro link
or train station it would be a business
uh
business use hotel and most of them will
be visiting cars
and we also have a gym and a pool
that will be open to i would assume
non-members or members of a gym in the
pool and again correct me if i'm wrong
if it's going to be is it only
residential use
so that i'll remove that bit then no
problem um
but again parking will be there not many
people from there
oh
the height is actually 13 storeys not 10
because you have the plant room you have
the restaurant and you have the open
roof bar
and
as i said at the very beginning the
reasons that we refused this
previously have not gone away
parking is an issue massing is an issue
and on-street parking would
is not available it's just not available
for that quality quantity of cars on
hornby road or wallet road and you can't
get access to
warrick road nor or so my busby way as
it is now
so for that reason i can't support this
application as is thank you
thank you i'm councillor minis
i'm similarly minded to council thomas i
think it's
sadly a monstrosity
um and it's huge
and
i don't know when i mean i think there's
a picture you put up that summed it up
really well where you had it next to
the houses um and i just thought oh my
god
and that was and the part that was
colored in was the part of the front and
not the parts that's such even bigger
you know imagine looking at living next
door to that and so i think that for me
it's overall messing
and the accessibility of the car parking
spaces um so having three disabled was
not enough
um i think a lot of people will come by
tram and train and things i think that
um
it bothers me less that part of it but
the disabled car parking space is not
enough and it's actually the size of the
thing it's too big that's not 10 stories
someone said it was 10 stories it's not
count how many windows there are going
up that's nine and then you've got
whatever that is that's on the top
that's another i don't know
three four windows worth there's dark
windows there but you know would be
could be whatever
with this crown thing so it's huge and
it's too big it's not the right place
for it
so it's a no from me
and i are happy to propose
we refuse the application thank you
just
for
the the the purpose of recording that
i'm not being very articulate that just
for clarification can we just confirm
the stories in the development
this is the best um elevation to show it
so
um the small section is four stories
and there's nine stories of residential
accommodation up to here
there's a story of resident um a story
for the rooftop
restaurant
and on top of that is a screened plant
so that's 11 stories to here
and then
oh sorry
so
so if you look at the the middle section
where you have this the smaller windows
up to there is nine stories
then there's a story above that where
there's a higher
level of lighter
blue that's that's the restaurant
on top of that is screened plant so it's
11 stories on that middle section
so that's the same
underneath the crown on on the tower and
then the crown obviously is not a story
it's
it's
it's 12 it's the equivalent of 12
stories as detailed in the report
and
yeah that that's that screened plant
it's not a story it's it's just it's
it's it's pla it's it's plants that's
just screened so that that's half the
story on the middle section and then the
full screen plant on top of the tower
element and then obviously it's it's
see-through there's no bulk there so
it's an equivalent of 12 stories but
actual flaws
of accommodation are 10.
[Music]
it
is
[Music]
um
just make one point clear from the from
the appeal decision and that it's to
make it clear that the inspector did not
dismiss
the um
the scheme on design and appearance the
inspector actually accepted that 16
stories of the previous application was
acceptable in this location
so i think we need to be clear
members need to have that clear in their
mind when they are considering the
application and and thinking about how
they they make their determination but
yes the inspector was clear that 16
stories in her mind was acceptable here
okay um councillor buntik
thank you chairman
dear me i've been looking forward to
this one coming back
um i think i had one or two words to say
last time this site was discussed and uh
i agree and concur with my colleagues
who have spoken previously that this
application is not a whole hell of a lot
better than the monstrosity that was
presented before us previously
if we're just going to make stuff up you
know it doesn't help i mean
i did that that section will look like
stitch leather
yeah it'll look like stitch leather in
the same way that i look like george
clooney i mean
it's just nonsense the idea that that
ridiculous crown structure on the top
does not constitute the height of the
building it's it's still bulk it's still
more
more building there and say oh it's not
a story it's a crown come on please
let's be sensible
in terms of the app reason for the
refusals i can fully concur in terms of
the
the size and scale and the bulk and the
massing i think it is far too large for
this building uh so far too low to this
site it has been toned down a little but
nowhere near enough in terms of the
design it was talked as being a high
quality design i would respectfully
disagree both of the architects who
unfortunately designed it and with the
appeals inspector who viewed it pre
reviewed the previous design i know they
say
beauty is in the either beholder but i'm
not quite sure what kind of eyes you'd
require
to look at that thing and say my god
isn't it gorgeous you know i mean it
just isn't
um in terms of the impacts upon the
locality and the people who live in this
area
well i have to come to this area
regularly uh for obvious reasons
and i'll be impacted upon it it will
be negative in my world but i can only
imagine the impact that it's going to
have on those who live in the immediate
area i i if this goes through then i
truly sympathize with you and i
apologize in advance
in terms of so in terms of this reason
i'm going to second council minister's
uh uh proposal to refuse it the building
is nowhere near dissimilar enough from
the building that was uh we refused
previously
i argue that yes it is
excessive in terms of its size scale
massing the bulk the shadowing and what
have you i do not agree
respectfully disagree in terms of the
design i think it is monstrous and will
be it was said to be i think distinctive
it's one of those planning words it
usually is a
uh
it's a way of saying ugly without saying
without actually coming out and saying
it you know it's of a distinctive
appearance
yeah i'm perhaps of a distinctive
appearance but i'm not suggesting they
put a 13 story statue of me in the area
because that would look equally hideous
um it really is just
beyond all possible reason and i cannot
possibly agree with the officer
recommendation so i will be voting
against office recommendation and i can
only hope that in future
common sense is brought into the
equation
basic reason is brought into the
equation and a slight consideration for
the people who live in the area is
brought into consideration and when this
site comes back is it will inevitably
will the design has been completely
reworked not just a slightly modeled
down version of the one that was there
before that has all the problems of the
one that was before
before or when i haven't mentioned
parking which i must admit i agree with
council thomas on that as well
so i will be voting in favor and i just
plea to the applicants can you please
see reason and
try and do something this is a far more
common sense that fits in with this area
far better and isn't just a toned down
version of your previous design thank
you chairman
thank you um
councillor thomas i think you're
indicating on the speaker
yeah we just to clarify that my
objection isn't particularly against the
design of the building it's around the
immunities and uh massing
thank you
um i can't see any of the members
indicating it present i mean i recall in
this when the previous application came
to committee and i spoke against at that
point um my concerns were pretty much
principally
relating to the height of the proposed
development as it then was
um and i have to say i i think the
applicant has
reflected on that and my concerns
weren't really embraced by the inspector
of my reading of
paragraph 113 if the report is correct
they were concerned pretty much solely
about
the impact of height upon number two but
the fact of the matter is that this is a
reduced um
the size of this development as proposed
now is it is smaller and i think that
the way the
the um there's a sort of
gradient of um
the way that the height of the towers
are distributed i think
it is much preferable to um the
application that was before us
previously um
mr match said in his comments the the
principal ground for um refusal appeal
by the inspector related to parking and
i have to say
i i think the applicant has gone some
way to
accommodate
a decent amount of parking given the
accessible nature of this site
um
i suppose i have some
sympathy with what the members of
council blunting in particular said
around design
but
look i don't think it uh deviates
so dramatically from other other
building types that you see in that part
of stratford so i suppose i think
the area can accommodate the the
the design and the the applicants
brought forward
so
i i i don't think that i am minded to um
support a refusal of this application i
think it is an improvement
on what was before his last time
and
a present i'd be minded to support her
um
now
we have only heard from three members
and then myself councillor walton
indicated
i find the description of this uh as a
tower a bit misleading because it's only
a tower in the asp in the sense that the
the sort of little brick exoskeleton at
the top
is sticking up above the the height of
the the bulk of the building in the
middle
um
i i i find that concerning i feel it's
being sold on a for on a false principle
and in fact it might be better if there
was a tower on that corner which uh as
as suggested
um you know a
defined tower
for me the stepping of it just seems to
add to the bulk of the building rather
than actually being a a nice limit
slimmer defined tower
and then you know and then a lower
section
of the building next door
um
i i'm really i'm
all the way through reading this
application i've been in two minds
because i really really understand what
where we're heading for this you know
for the for the civic quarter and i know
and
and i do think you know a hotel on that
site could make a major contribution to
the uh to the area i think some of the
claims for it you know for the greenery
and that kind of thing may be a bit
a bit overblown um in terms of the the
planting and the uh um
uh around the building i don't
it's not laying it on in spades in in
the way that a lot of modern buildings
are with green walls and that kind of
thing okay there's a there's a green
roof but you're not going to see a huge
amount of that from from the roadway
but my biggest my biggest problem with
it is probably the um the access to the
uh
to the
to the building on that corner
and you're going to have a lot of
service vehicles going in there
you're going to have a you know
i would at least expect there to be a
continuous footwear
along there which basically says
that the pedestrians have priority i
mean i know that that might be something
that can be looked at in the plans
later on but at the moment it looks like
it's a it's an opening off the road i
think they should people if you're
accessing that site you should be
driving off over
effectively a you know a drop curve over
the pavement so it tells anybody who's
accessing that site that pedestrians
have priority um
at the very least but it's a it is a
really difficult
it looks like a really difficult corner
for to have a lot of traffic going in in
and out on a residential road
thank you um i think ms lowe's just
wanted to make a point of qualification
yes thank you chair and just on that the
access is the existing access so the
access doesn't change that currently
saves an existing office building so
there's currently it's currently used as
there's currently ground floor surface
car parking
for that office unit that's accessed
from that same access presently and
so so that doesn't change and as um
we've talked about the car parking will
be managed by a valet system so it won't
be residents turning up at that access
point
as they please to park there will be a
valet system that will be managed by the
car park by the by the hotel operators
and the cars will be taken into that
access
via um
employees of the hotel it won't it won't
be the the residents that that um
actually access that point so just to
make that to make that clear
thank you um council chalking
thank you and
i'll admit when i first read the report
i was all in favor of this it sounded
really good and
um the work that's been done by the
applicant and officers alike is is
welcome
it's
the report itself was was really really
helpful um in terms of drawing our
attention to where things have been
changed but i still
sit quite uncomfortably with it now um i
have been to hornby road
i imagined it and i thought well it's
still
rather large i just think this is too
big
um for
that area um
i appreciate the comments about access
but
it's not a it's not a fantastic area
anyway for vehicular access um 169 rooms
you know on a match day if it's going to
be full i
i just go back to what i just said it's
i just think it's too big um it will
overlook the gardens on hornby road it's
uh
i appreciate the work that's been done
to try and mitigate that but it is going
to be ugly to them it is going to be
unsightly
and i know that's noted in the report
to a degree um
i just go back to what i said it i just
think it's too big so i i really can't
find sit here and say i support this
notwithstanding the comments that have
been made by the um
inspectorates on the last application
uh
i i just think it's the wrong
development for this site
and counts the winter stanley
thanks chair i really wanted to like it
i know the developers worked with the
the council officers to try and come up
with something which is acceptable
and i don't think uh i'd object to a
hotel on this site i'm not sure that the
the residents who spoke would go after a
hotel on the site i think the object to
this i mean i went back the original
appeal which was turned down where the
uh the inspector said it would have a an
effect on adjacent residential
properties will be stalking omnipresence
the original one would be so would this
highway safety not enough parking and
would cause inconvenience reliance on
on-street parking i don't think 22
parking space is going to be much
different to that
uh accessibility the hotel the hotel
itself is accessible bizarrely if you
come by public transport and there's
lots of
accessibility
uh in terms of disabled accessibility
and the design of the
of the hotel itself but three accessible
parking spaces is not enough and i know
we apply i think it's five percent we
apply for the percentages of available
parking spaces but that's predicated on
the fact that there would be sufficient
parking spaces for
161 rooms on that basis you'd need
almost 10 accessible parking spaces
um and to think that people will
disabled people go to this place by
public transport in greater manchester
you clearly haven't tried to travel as a
disabled person on public transport in
greater manchester
um
i think this will come back
i think it will come back and if there's
if there's a better design i'd be happy
to support it but not in this format
thank you chair
thank you and counselor hassan
it is really
it it could be a very exciting and a
very innovative addition to the to the
to an old trafford is the border of my
constituency
and it is a well-known international
uh tourist
attraction
and oh it is the dire need for this area
to have a beautiful hurdle in that area
uh
i fully understand that then in regards
to my colleagues are saying because i'm
not a architecture to be honest why this
building is looking ugly or whatever i
can't comment on that
uh why it is so big
uh building
uh i don't know because if we have any
other presidents already in that area on
that side of buildings
and i don't think this is a bad addition
and
it will give a boost
to the economy to the local economy and
the unemployment
and a parking is an internationally it
is a national issue
give me one example of any any
development there is a walking issue
parking is always an issue
and
this hotel will be
a facility to the tourists who was
coming by trams and
that they are using
uh where a well-connected place when the
people will be coming to visit old
trafford
cricket or football or whatever
so it it could be a very good
very exciting
uh addition to that area
if
uh
i mean the office is considered
very is really a very
bad addition so in regards to the story
i don't understand it i'm
i
i will i will like it i will recommend
it strongly the
the officer's recommendations
if it is not
the planet should come back
if they can reduce the because
if we compare the
the number of rooms
and
the parking
so there are only 29 parking spaces am i
right
yeah and the number of rooms are 169. so
if it is
50 50 will be okay because the guests
start coming in
and
there'll be a massive issue in regards
to the parking otherwise it is a good
addition to be honest
i don't mind to say it yes it is
thank you
thank you councilman um councillor
thomas
thank you just briefly and i take on and
i appreciate the valley parking
where where are the cars going to be
picked up for by the valleys on the
double yellow line outside
across the road outside the pub
there's nothing in the plums to suggest
that there's any
visit
the pavement's intact they can't park on
the pavement
yes this is going to be a drop off and
pick up bay on um the the
hotel side of work road
that's nice
i believe it is but i'll try and find a
plan and and demonstrate that but that
that's the plan that those so we're
restricting the payment as well
so it will um so you wear the um
the
sorry i can't get my weights out okay
optional
forwarders normally have their stalls
on match days
that will be the um drop off bay and on
match days the traders stalls will um
will will utilize that area as well
so we are restricting the payment
no the pavement will will remain it will
be cut into the it'll be part of the
pavement and part of the road so we are
restricting the pavement
yeah yes there'll be some sufficient
pavement remaining thank you
can i ask a question with official
please uh
i mean i know this area very well i've
been believing there for 20 years and
in regards to do we have any access to
other other areas and there are only two
or three minutes walk to other stratfor
road and other roads where people can
park or there are free free parking
available on those areas and then people
can park the tourist and car park and go
and stay in the hutter
am i
[Music]
yes thank you chairman just two further
points just
one i agree with councilman stanley yes
it's gonna come back and if it comes
about the sensible design i'll happily
vote for it myself uh i would be more
than happy to see a sensible design uh
on this site and i will enthusiastically
support it if we get one but this is not
it and i just cannot in all
consciousness inflict this on the area
uh and the people who live within it and
two uh the other point i want to make
that much much made of
increased traffic regulation or doing
what have you that's not a plan for
management that's what you do when
things go wrong
putting more traffic
to more traffic regulations it's more
you can't park here more you can't park
there extending the hours that you can't
park in and all the rest of it that's
what you do when things go wrong it's
not a plan for the future so uh
the parking issue this is already an
area which is a
completely breaking point in relation to
parking it's not an area with a few
parking issues that might get a bit
worse it's already in the area that is
at its limit and i also concur the
additional restriction of the pocket of
the pavement is going to be another
negative impact i haven't been mentioned
previously so i thank councillor thomas
for pointing that one out as well thank
you chairman
thank you um councillor hartley
thank you chair
i do have reservations about this i i i
don't like the the appearance of it but
i'm but i'm not sure
i'm not sure that's enough so i i think
the
the height of the building
uh isn't a problem the inspector
identified that on the last uh on the
last appeal but the the appearance and
the massing of it is is different it's
lower and
wider there seems to be more of it and
there were comments from the inspector
last time around the
you know the height and
that it wouldn't um
you know it wouldn't it wouldn't stick
out too much it wouldn't be too
oppressive and but part of the reasoning
for that was around the
um
the palette of the materials being
varied and we could see that on the
pitch is actually the last scheme
which i seem to remember i was quite
critical of though and probably not as
critical as cancer bunting but it did
have a it did have a a change in in
palette so it seemed to have a better
transition in some ways whereas this
does seem to be quite
quite um uniform in its appearance so
i'm i'm you know i'm not keen on it but
i think
you know i think the problem is it might
not come back here because the developer
might appeal and they might be
successful on appeal and that and that
is a distinct possibility i think um
the the parking i do have some sympathy
with
what the inspector said on the appeal
was that
having no on-site parking is not
acceptable and there is some on-site
parking there the question is you know
is 20 spaces enough for 169 bedrooms and
there is um
you know there is in the civic quarter
area as a whole there's an excess of
parking space do i accept a lot of that
will be in in private hands and i
suppose you know the final the final
point i'll probably make is i know the
area action plan is not finalized but i
think it it still has um
still has moderate weight and there
isn't in that there isn't much in the
action plan which would point against
this for me it encourages hotel
development
the the heart it's in accordance with
the height parameters set out uh in that
in that plan uh and the building that's
there at the moment has a negative
impact and i and i can see that so
i'm i'm not a huge fan but i do think
there is a risk that if we um
if we refuse permission here will be
appealed and successfully appealed but i
would i would love to see a better
scheme
i just think you know my personal view
on the appearance is obviously not
enough to
to refuse permission here thank you
thank you councillor maitland
thanks chair
um
i've i don't know whether anybody else
has sent one of these
things yeah
um
and one of the things that i've noticed
is is how much the the back gardens of
hornby road are overlooked
and i'd hate to be living in those
houses to be honest
um
parking is another issue with me but the
other thing is i don't understand the
crown
i think it's giving it excessive height
anyway so
why have it i don't know i'm not an
architect i don't understand but
it's as if it looks not finished but um
it's definitely the parking and the um
overlooking for me as well
sorry
i agree
ms i think did you
thank you and just for council thomas's
benefit i've just popped up the this
plan which um shows the drop-off point
and that's clear so the building would
be set back slightly to to allow
sufficient pedestrian and footwears
around and then there would be an area
here for drop-offs and pickups and
i also have a slide which shows the
differences in massing between the
existing and proposed um schemes and i
wonder if members would be if that would
be useful for members to
to see so um the red
outline is the previous
refused scheme and the blue outline is
the current proposals so we can see
there's significant well there's a
there's a good portion of mass and
height that has been taken off the
current proposals and and reduced down
and so just thought that was useful and
for members to to kind of see that and
one other thing is just to pick up on
the someone just mentioned overlooking
just to be clear that
um in the previous appeal decision
overlooking was not a reason that the
inspector dismissed the the appeal it
was the impact on outlook and its
overbearing nature so i think we just
need to be careful if we're going
towards a refusal on on how we're
looking to to to weight that
as in reasons expressed as this
yeah thank you for those that's really
helpful and visual demonstration as well
um as i i understand to think
um
mrs coley and um
mr fisher also want to make a fifth
point is it
uh yeah
i think well jerry it's really for
following this debate uh i just wanted
to make make a point if if that's all
right
that's fine um i mean it has been
proposed and seconded that um
permission be refused contrary to
officer recommendation i think we've
spoken at length now um with this item
so i think miss coley just wanted to
clarify reasons that have been expressed
and and also
um
[Music]
given the previous appeal decision
whether or not there's any risks
associated with that thank you
thank you thank you chairman um i've
i've heard from the record what i think
of five reasons for refusal um the
first on the height and the massing of
the building
and the second on there not being enough
parking or um or and that and then
following on from that not enough
disabled parking
poor design of the building in terms of
its appearance impact on the immunity of
neighbouring properties both in terms of
their outlook
and in terms of overlooking
and the restriction of the pavement
through the
introduction of the
parking bay is there anything i've
missed
no thank you i will take i'll take that
as a
um
that i've been listening at least um
um
as members are aware there has been a
previous appeal decision on on this site
and the previous uh refusal from this
committee
um and that appeal decision is is
members will know a um important
material consideration in in the
determination of this application it
cannot be set aside and should not be
set aside and obviously that sets some
parameters by which uh any future scheme
may or may not be considered acceptable
um
in in in particular
uh and i've heard what members have said
about this that that that appeal
decision did say that a 16-story
building was appropriate on this site
and thereby saying that a smaller
building is not appropriate on this site
in in direct opposition to that decision
made by an inspector would put the
council at risk at an appeal and indeed
in at risk of an award of costs
also in terms of the height um the area
action plan does say 12-story building
is appropriate on this site
that area action plan submission draft
in which it's which it's in was
approved by this planning committee so
you have a pre-effectively approved plan
which says you can have a 12-story
building on this site so again a reason
for refusal which um
which directly contradicts that would
put the council uh
at an award of cost that is tempered
slightly by the fact that the area
action plan has not yet um
been through examination however there
are no objections um to that particular
element of of the plan and nobody has
sought to speak in respect of of this
site
um the third thing is in terms of the
accessible parking standards that the
the three
is policy compliant i understand uh
councilman stanley's point about the
fact that there should be more parking
therefore there should be more
accessible parking but as i purport but
as a proportional number it is policy
compliant
so i would advise that if going down
that route um that the
objection is to the overall parking
numbers including accessible parking as
opposed to the accessible numbers
parking numbers per se
um
uh it it also needs to be noted that
your technical highways advice
um
raises no objection to this scheme so a
refusal on parking highways um and the
impact from the drop-off bay
all go against the professional advice
you've had
with no technical evidence that that
i've seen and no technical evidence that
i've heard from members um
rather assertion that this would not be
a satisfactory situation um
ms lowe's has clarified that the access
arrangements are the existing access
arrangements and of course there is an
office building on that site so all in
all i've heard what members have said
my advice is my advice i can't require
you to go one way or another but i do
think if if members refuse the
application this evening that uh it is
very likely that an appeal would be uh
granted and i also think that the
council is does put itself at risk of a
cost award um
for if if not for all the reasons
certainly for for a couple of them thank
you chairman
thank you
um
so with that it has been proposed in a
second did the
um permission be refused contrary to
officer recommendation
members of content would like to proceed
to the vote
yes okay um members supporting the
motion that permission be refused can
indicate now please
yeah okay and
members not supporting that motion they
can indicate now
okay
okay um permission is refused for that
application
yeah
thank you chair um just for following
the um
uh the debate on that application i just
have a quick request of of members if i
may um
uh obviously your role here is to
comment on on the applications and to
determine them and occasionally it is
necessary to to do so with a degree of
force and color in order to articulate
your point but the committee does sit in
a quasi-judicial uh uh role for the
authority so i simply ask that you do
use uh choose your words carefully when
commenting on applications um because it
is uh it's a formal process uh and the
language we use does need to reflect
that so i just be grateful for that uh
for future applications uh thank you
thank you chen thank you thank you very
much um
mitti will now consider applications 105
247 105 248 and 105 249
all of which relate to moss cottage in
bowdoin that can be fined on pages 145
170 186
of the committee report
as these applications relate to the same
site we will have
one
conversation
one introduction and one discussion
relating to the items but there will be
three separate votes um in respect of
the permissions
um
the the other thing to say is as there
is one discussion to all three items
please can members make it clear
which permission they're referring to
and what aspects of the proposed
developments they're commenting on that
that would be much appreciated and so
the introduction we will now receive is
from miss coley
thank you chairman um
as the chairman has said uh we will be
taking these three applications together
but with but with three votes equally my
introduction covers all three of the the
applications um so um
it's it's relatively brief in relation
to them individually but
please bear with me because obviously
when you combine the three do do
remember that i'm talking about three
three applications here
so there are three applications before
members this evening relating to the
moss cottage on south dalles road in
bowdoin
these are a householder planning
application
which seeks consent for two single story
side extensions a rear infill extension
a link structure between the two roof
ridges formation of a new vehicular
access and the erection of its attached
garage secondly a listed building
consent application which seeks consent
for the erection of two stories single
story side extensions a rear infill
extension a link structure between the
two roof ridges and internal alterations
comprising the reconfiguration of the
20th century ranges layout
and with the list of building consent
the work that you are only considering
the works to the building itself to the
listed building itself so that excludes
anything that is happening with within
the cartilage uh you were also
considering works for the interior as
well as the exterior of the building
when considering a list of building
consent
and thirdly a full planning application
seeking consent for the subdivision of
the site and the erection of extensions
to an existing garage to form a detached
dwelling
moss cottage is a grade two listed
cottage within the ashley heath
conservation area the cottage is built
in red brick and has a thatched roof a
dormer to the front elevation bears the
date 1666
the cottage is set within a relatively
large plot which provides an attractive
landscape setting there is a detached
single-story structure to the north
corner of the site which forms a garage
in a studio
this is accessed along a setted driveway
from marlborough road
for the householder planning application
the key issues are the impact of the
proposal on the significance and setting
of the grade 2 listed moss cottage
the impact on the character of the
appearance the ashley heath conservation
area and the impact on protected species
there are further concerns relating to
the quality of the submitted drawings
the internal alterations to moss cottage
are not considered under this
application
so as you see on the
plan in front of you there there's the
existing elevations and
two sections through
moss cottage
existing plans so if you can't see my
cursor here that's the um
the original part of the building you
see that's the timber framing
um and then the
modern range at the rear
and then you see the proposed
uh plans and elevations you've got two
extensions one to each side a
conservatory style extension on that
side
a lean to on on that side you can see
these here extending either side that's
the original building that's the
60s range
um
and then
i don't know why it's gone blue uh
and this is uh when we say we've got
some concerns about the submissive plans
this is one of them this is all the only
plans we have for the garage that we
only have um a front and a side
elevation we don't have complete but
that's not the only the only thing
that's missing and that's the garage
proposal
that's the cottage itself
that's the one of the side elevations
rear
another side
and another rear which shows the sight
of the proposed garage
so i'll go back
to
the plans try and get that blue off
there you go
okay
so
the statutory starting point for the
planning application is the development
plan
statutory duties related to preservation
listed buildings and conservation areas
are engaged the tilted balance is not
engaged
as it's the view of offices that harm
designated heritage assets provides a
clear reason for the refusal of the
application
the proposed extensions would impact on
the modest and diminutive character of
moss cottage and would not respect its
architectural style
the new vehicular access would remove
hedging and increase views into the site
whilst the garage would be a large
structure erected close to moss cottage
this would be at odds with the silver
and spacious character of the site the
proposals are considered by officers to
cause major harm to the significance of
moscow cottage and moderate harm to its
setting the proposals would also cause
moderate harm to the character and
appearance of the ashley heath
conservation area and these harms would
constitute less than substantial harm in
mppf terms but at the upper end of the
scale
it is to be noted that our heritage
development officer
objects to this application and the
other two applications before you this
evening in in very strong terms
economic activity associated with
construction works would be the only
public benefit of the scheme
it is considered that the harm to
designated heritage assets would not be
outweighed by this public benefit this
provides a clear reason for refusing the
application
in addition moss cottage has been
assessed as having moderate to high back
roosting potential and the application
is not supported by adequate surveys
bats are a european protected species
protected under the conservation
habitats and species regulations 2017
where a protective species license is
required planning permission should only
be granted where the local planning
authorities satisfied that the three
licensing tests are met
it is recommended that a lack of
suitable bat surveys forms a reason for
refusal and indeed without those bat
surveys um the planning authority would
not be able to discharge its um duties
under the habitat's regs
if
members were minded to grant the
application
um the submitted drawings containing
inaccuracies and do not provide the
level of detail expected for an
application to extend a listed building
a full set of elevations of the proposed
garage have also not been submitted it
is therefore not possible to fully
assess the extent of the impact schemes
impact it is recommended that this forms
a reason for refusal
it's also noted that in some of the
correspondence um
it's said that that the plans have
already been
approved previously there
was a planning application that wasn't
implemented for a small element of this
um of this house
the house extension proposals um which
is
the
extension
at the rear there
um
other than for that particular element
other than the issue with the level of
detail on the proposed plans officers
would have no objection to that so our
object objection is is primarily with
the two with the two side extensions
and therefore for the house extension
it's considered that the harm to
designated heritage assets provides a
clear reason for the refusal of the
application furthermore the lack of
adequate bat surveys and issues of the
accuracy and level of detail of the
submitted drawings also weigh against
the scheme it's recommended the
application is refused
for the list of building consent
only the impact of physical works in
respect to the preservation of the
architectural historic importance the
listed building itself can be considered
the statutory duty for listed buildings
is tilted balance which presumes in
favor of preservation i.e in favor of
refusal and special regard must be paid
to this the development plan and the
mppf are material considerations but
only insofar as they relate to listed
building matters no other issues are
relevant to the determination listed
building consent application
the erection of the detached garage and
formation the new vehicular access are
not considered under the application for
listed building consent
as set out above and for the same reason
the extensions to moss cottage would be
at odds with his diminutive scale and
vernacular character the level of detail
on the submitted drawings are not of the
required standard for enlisted building
consent there is therefore insufficient
information to fully understand and
assess the internal alterations
um and it's the view of officers that
works would not preserve the
architectural historic importance of the
listed building
it's also considered that if members
were minded to grant the applications of
the basically information we have in
front of us that they would not be able
to discharge their statutory duty in
respect of
listed building matters
it's considered that the proposal would
cause major harm to the significance of
moss cottage and moderate harm to its
setting these would be categorised as
less of substantial harm in mppf terms
it's therefore recommended that listed
building consent is refused
for the full planning application the
key issues are the impact of the
proposal of the setting of the mosque
cottage and its impact on the character
and appearance of the ashley heath
conservation area the statutory starting
point of the development plan
the statutory duties relating to the
preservation of listed buildings in the
conservation area are also engaged
the tilted balance is not engaged as it
is the view of offices that the harm to
designated heritage assets provides a
clear reason for refusal
planning commission has previously been
refused for a similar proposal most
recently in 2017 an appeal inspector
dismissed an appeal in 2010 finding
harmed the setting of the listed
building in the conservation area this
appeal decision is an important material
consideration in the determination of
the planning application
officers consider that the subdivision
of the site would harm its spacious
character whilst the erection of
substantial extensions to the detached
garage would unacceptably increase the
amount of built form at the site this
would detract from the diminutive scale
of moss cottage and the spacious and
leafy character of its setting in the
wider conservation area
the design of the extensions to the
garage in order to
convert it to a dwelling are considered
to be a poor quality and would not
reflect the historic character of the
application site or the conservation
area
that that being that if this was not an
application for subdivision of the plot
um we would be recommending refusal of
that the application on the design of
the building alone and in terms of the
impact it has on the conservation area
it's the view of offices that the
proposal will cause major harm to the
setting of the grade 2 listed moss
cottage a major harm to the character
and appearance of the ashley heath
conservation area in both cases this
would be at the upper end of less than
substantial harm in
mppf terms the proposal provides one
family dwelling on a sustainably located
site there would also be a minor
economic benefit associated with
construction works these are the public
benefits of the scheme it is the view of
offices that harm to designated heritage
assets clearly outweighs those public
benefits
this provides a clear reason for the
reviews of the application
finally i would draw members attention
to the additional information report
as the original committee report
included recommended reason for refusal
which related to a lack of sufficient
tree protection information
the applicant has submitted the
additional information to demonstrate
the application is acceptable in this
regard and this therefore no longer
forms a recommended reason for refusal
and those reasons have been struck out
thank you chair
thank you mrs coley um there is one
speaker speaking against the
applications um so in support of the
refusal recommendation
it's christopher payne who i understand
has submitted a statement which will be
read out by ms milner
thank you chair so this is um on behalf
of doctor and mrs payne at to
marlborough road we note the complexity
of this report and we respect the time
spent and the detail that the report
contains we would like to confirm that
our objections to this application
remain unchanged and we respectfully
refer back to our previous submission
dated the 8th of september 2021
we do believe that we would be severely
and adversely affected by the proposed
development i would like to draw your
attention to an error in relation to our
address
which is to melba road not to blend in
close which refers to a completely
different properties some two houses
further down planning close our main
entrance is on marlborough road
i confirm that we share the common
boundary with moss cottage we know that
the application has been referred to the
planning development committee because
of the five letters of support but
always
but we respectfully point out that none
of these five properties are affected or
directly overlooked
by the proposed new development and
several are a considerable distance from
moss cottage
i would refer to the latest tree survey
which does cause some concern as it
seems to refer to a desire to alter and
decrease the boundary trees and hedges
between our two properties therefore
thereby adversely affecting our privacy
and amenity we would want to object to
such a proposal if we have interpreted
these matters correctly
the proposed new building is
considerably larger than the present
single-story garage it would replace and
it is planned to extend along a large
part of the boundary between our
properties
it will dominate the rear view from our
property and this
and this effect is magnified by the fact
it will
be built only three feet from the
boundary between the two properties as
such it will directly overlook the
lounge a smaller morning room and the
kitchen on our ground floor and the main
bedroom a smaller bedroom and a study on
the first floor
this will have a considerably negative
effect on the aspect and privacy of our
own property
in addition it will have a similarly
negative effects in relation to the
views and privacy regards
to our garden which will be directly
overlooked an effect which will be
significantly magnified in the summer
months
we also understand there will be a
significant effect with regard to light
availability in our garden as a result
of the size of the planned building and
its planned proximity to the boundary
between the two properties
finally we have great concerns that
there will be inevitable damage to the
intervening boundary trees shrubs and
hedgerows as a direct result of the
building such a large house within three
feet of the boundary mindful of the fact
that the proposed new building would lie
in a conservation area
such damage seems to be to be both
permanent and unavoidable if building
goes ahead and we do not wish to lose
any of the boundary trees shrubs and
hedgerows which are vital and much
valued part of our privacy and enjoyment
thank you for your consideration
thank you um the two people speaking
in favor of granting permission for
these applications uh chris griffiths
and councillor wetton if you decided
who'd like to speak
hi mr griffiths thanks for joining us um
you've got nine minutes to speak if you
do run over time i'll just ask that you
wrap up your contribution and if you can
just make sure that the microphone's on
turn would be appreciated thank you
that's already thank you very much
uh good evening members and thank you
for this opportunity to uh to address
you on behalf of
my client the applicant mrs harrison
i will be talking to all three
applications um but focusing primarily
on the listed building and the
householder application just uh so you
know you're aware um i i prepared the
heritage statement into in support of
the scheme
i got 22 years experience as a consul as
a heritage
expert in the field of historic building
conservation including 14 years as a
local authority conservation officer
um
the
um
so yeah first of all just to point out
that the the the
application for the
separate dwelling at medicroft has
previously been approved um
originally in 1982 and that was renewed
in 1985 1990 in 1995
and it finally lapsed in in the year
2000
but that planning history is obviously a
material consideration in this
application um
so the the
council's representative has already
mentioned that the heritage assets we're
concerned with our moss cottage there's
a great two listed building and ashley
heath conservation area that's a matter
of established common ground
first thing to say that moss cottage is
a very fascinating building about which
we know a surprising amount it's a rare
example
of a pair of farm labourers cottages
dating from the restoration period and
it's got its own date on it 1666.
it was built for robert and helen lewis
but we don't know too much about them
the dimension of duality about the
building as a pair of cottages
is a very interesting aspect of its
history um and that remains legible in
in in the extant fabric of the building
and the cellular structure that the pair
of chimneys to each um of the the gabled
ends to the northeast and the north west
and southeast sides
um and the
chronology of the building so it the the
the social history um through census
records demonstrates that it has had two
separate owners um up until the
20th century and in 1881 you had for
example a wheel right known as ben
benjamin smith and he lived in the
northern part
um
and a garden uh a day gardener lived in
the
adjoining
cottage
and uh
the the his heritage statement which i
assume we've all read um goes into some
detail about how this aspect of
two cottages is um
quite
quite distinctive and something that
we've
um sought to draw out and to
emphasize through the proposed
alterations
but looking at the house
in the present day the current owner has
lived here since 1982 and and although
it's a very quaint building
um it's not well suited as a family
residence uh it lacks
storage space um
and ground floor living areas uh are
certainly lacking in terms of the the
amount of room there is um
and in my view it's evidently capable of
absorbing the sort of change which is
um put forward in these proposals in the
form of sympathetic alterations
and these are incremental in nature that
do not in my view harm the significance
of the listed building
um and they are modeled closely in what
was there throughout the 19th century up
till at least 1908
and they've been
carefully designed spoke in a bespoke
manner
and expressed in traditional materials
and
these will emphasize the
historic development of the the cottage
as a pair
coupled with alterations such as the
reinstatement of the second front door
to the left-hand side
as you look at it from south downs road
um and and the the the differences in
the hierarchy of the building is is
evident on the inside for example the
carving of the beams to the um
the left-hand cottage are distinct from
those in the other part
um
and
although it was extended in around 1960
um effectively doubling the footprint
this proposal
um exploits those opportunities to
enhance the building's historic and
architectural interest while at the same
time enhancing its long-term
conservation by improving its viability
as a family house
the requirement to preserve the
building's special interest in my view
has been has been met in all respects
and this has uh has been balanced with
the need for change in order to adapt
the building
to make it fit for purpose um because
buildings do need to be adapted to make
them more sustainable
and that the intention is obviously to
maintain it as a single residence but
more suitable for family life
in my view the proposed changes will
reinforce the building's significance
and notably hits its historic use as a
pair of cottages although it's remaining
a single dwelling
um by putting on these side extensions
which have clear historic precedent
that's proven through photographic
records
and maps and and they're in the heritage
statement and i must say it was
somewhat disappointing and surprising
um to encounter the conservation
officers approach to the proposals
it just seemed very closed-minded
which is unfortunate i think given that
buildings need to adapt
to
ensure that they're maintained and
sustained for the foreseeable future
the the proposals will also uh reinforce
the building's association with moss
farm and barn to the south of
south downs road
by virtue of the subtle remodeling
of the the cartilage and the boundary
treatment
um
which will become very much closer to
what it was before 1940
um when it and and when it was a pair of
farm labourers cottages
this change within the setting would
reinforce the simple character of the
asset as a vernacular pair of cottages
built for farm laborers
and the building's humble origins um
really are an aspect of its history and
significance that are tend to be lost by
the enormity of the the garden plot
which in which it's immersed
um
and it's worth saying at this point that
the proposed garage which is described
in the committee report as some enormous
um
addition within the grounds is a very
diminutive and entirely sympathetic
structure
and that the council if if it wants the
additional elevations can certainly have
them because
the sim the idea is that it's a very
simple structure with a lean to and in
my view would not harm the setting in
any way shape or form
in summary the
and with the benefit of 22 years
experience in the field of heritage
historic building conservation and as a
conservation officer
and expert witness
i commend this pro proposal to you as an
exemplar of intelligently managed change
and it
epitomizes precisely the kind of changes
to a listed building which would
conserve and sustain its significance in
concordance with the government's
objectives for sustainable development i
don't know why you're laughing
and as these are set out in the mppf
the full planning application for
meadowcroft
in my view will deliver a high quality
designed new residence within the
northern part of the garden
grounds of the property
it itself will retain a generous garden
plot
and one has to bear in mind the the
evolution which has taken place in this
part of the conservation area um over
time and look at recent approvals of the
sort to the east so for example wood
ends a very very large
new building which has
been built over the last four years and
we sent in some pictures of this to
demonstrate
you know the contrast with the proposed
um
very diminutive structure new house that
is proposed for meadowcroft
and i i consider this to be commensurate
in size and scale and very much
complementary to the setting of the
listed building
the visuals accompanying the application
demonstrate that the new house would
have no noticeable effect on the
character and appearance of the
conservationist mr griffiths i think you
have run over if you can just finish
your point yeah i'm just coming to that
now yeah
and would not harm its significance
that's the conservation area's
significance
likewise the setting of the listed
building would be preserved for the
purpose of the statutory duty under
section 66 1. i therefore also commend
this application
to members for approval in compliance
with paragraph 206 of the mppf
thank you for your time
thank you thank you um councillor wetton
um you have as you're speaking to all
three applications you have 15 minutes
to speak if you do one overtime i'll
just lightly ask that you wrap up your
contribution thank you
[Music]
thank you and good evening
um i have to say that having heard the
case for the prosecution from mrs coley
it seems i face
an uphill struggle
but here we go
and uh can i just say for those
committee members who don't really know
me i used to be a member of this
committee for many years
in my time serving on the committee and
i know it's a tough job of work to be on
this committee the reading the visiting
the assessing most importantly making
crucial decisions
so in my time here i used
various measures of my own as well as
considering the plethora of guidance and
regulation and red tape
whatever the application i would ask
myself
does it add anything to the community
will it sit comfortably in its setting
does it add anything to trafford such as
homes
council tax or jobs
will it be a good neighbor
this application is ticking
those boxes
and perhaps it is important for me to
say early on that this application could
possibly take on misleading proportions
is it enormous
three applications on one residential
site
well the proportion that i see is a
house or a home
seeking a sympathetic extension to
improve quality of life
continuation of the sympathetic
maintenance of the grade two listed
property
and an application to build a house
where a house used to be
i'm not going to try and deal with the
technicalities of the grade 2 listing
but i will make some layman's
observations in this in this respect
because i feel that it is vital that we
approach this with eyes opened to the
real world
and if i may i will share that i do have
some personal experience of the
pressures of maintaining some grade two
listed properties
it's a constant burden one not to be
taken lightly
and the applicant does not take it
lightly
anyone who has made a site visit will
have seen that
for themselves
the quality of the maintenance of the of
the cottage in particular
the building we are discussing has a
history it's a long history as i'm sure
you know it was built in the same year
as the great fire of london
so of course it has a history
but it's also a house a home
and a home in the modern age
it has electricity
it has a very modern stove installed
it has an indoor toilet
the applicant has undertaken painstaking
and vital restoration sympathetically
over the years
including replacing over a thousand of
the original bricks which were crumbling
replacing beams
that needed replacing re-thatching
reflooring
and more
over its life the house has changed it
was extended in the 1960s that's 60
years ago
and it needs to change again marginally
to keep fulfilling its role as a home
a proper home a safe home
it is a home looking to be continued as
a home for many years to come
some things need to be added or altered
in order to take it forward as a grade
two listed home
i will just endeavor to make some points
in response to some of the references in
in the report now
on page 154
paris six
referring to section 66 of the planning
listed building and conservation areas
act it tells us that the planning
authority shall have special regard to
the desirability of preserving the
building
this is certainly desirable and the
proposals being put forward by extending
it will still protect the building that
sits there today
in paris seven section 72 refers to the
desirability
of preserving or enhancing the character
of the building
well in my view this application does
both
para eight on policy l7 of the traffic
core strategy says that design and
development must be appropriate in its
context
well of course it's appropriate in its
context just as the other house applied
for will be
because they were here before the
mansion next door which came along much
later
best use of opportunities is mentioned
surely this must be seen as a huge
opportunity with best use certainly
being made of it
power 13 on page 155 refers to the
impact of development on the
significance of a heritage asset
the
significance in this sense being the
value of the heritage asset to future
generations
significance derives we are told from an
asset's physical presence and its
setting
i believe that these proposals meet the
significance aspect certainly in its
presence and definitely in its setting
these are not unreasonable requests that
are sought to carry out to be carried
out
adding some additional space is not
unreasonable how many houses today are
extended in today's world
in today's trafford where everyone wants
to live of course
and it keeps this committee and our
planners very busy dealing with all of
those
extensions this very house has
historically been extended because it
used to be two homes
but times moved on even back in the day
and two homes were merged today make a
larger home here
it now seeks to be a little bit bigger
it needs the two modest extensions
that more than it needs to be the
subject picture of a lid of box the lid
of a box of chocolates
considering that there used to be a side
extension where one is sought now it's
not an unfair request to be to rebuild
one and balance it with another on the
other side of the building
isn't that taking it back to part of its
heritage
a lot is made of the bat report
situation
and there is an audit trail that
explains that delay in the providing of
a warm month back report
the one month back report is ordered for
the fifth of may
i think some of us might be busy that
day but it's ordered for that day
and i've been advised
at a very high level that awaiting this
report does not prevent you as the
planning committee from approving this
application today
conditionally subject to an acceptable
warm
month back report
in terms of heritage and conservation
where does the line get drawn on a
property that is so old as to have its
own history
the cottage used to be two dwellings it
used to have one side extension it used
to have earth floors come to that it
used to have dry rot it doesn't now
so who decides the point where the video
has to be freeze framed
who what decides where the picture gets
frozen
who decides what is right for the
interior layout of someone's
long-established home
well in this case tonight it is you the
committee
so i urge you to consider the situation
of the applicant and see what the need
is here
the benefits that can be derived here
and that by approving it you add life
and more history to the building
metacroft
used to be a house on the site of the
current garage quite clearly a house
stood there before now
this is a modest request to put a house
on that site again the overall site is
large enough to take it
we can see from location plans that many
similar size plots exist nearby
from and
from the aerial view that i sent out
there is clearly ample provision
the heritage officer considers the
subdividing of the site to be
unacceptable
there is an irie an irony here in in
that as much as there used to be two
houses two sites on this over all
location
the land registry document sent out um
that that i sent out indicates it was
two plots
so the irony is that two plots will be
returning to our heritage
the aerial view
gives a helpful aid to the overall scale
of the location
it is clearly capable of accommodating
two houses
ask yourself honestly how many houses
would retro or barrett's fit on such a
site
the council previously approved a
replacement house on this site
and renewed that approval three times so
in effect four approvals
probably four completely different
committees
the applicant failed to build and failed
to renew due to particular circumstances
uh which i i'm not privy to
nevertheless there was once an approval
for a house on the
and i've been on this committee more
than once when
an application has been approved
for an extension
because
for for any development because it there
was previously
an approval of the same sort of thing
it is difficult to accept the concerns
of the impact of another house
near to moss cottage when someone
approved the dominant neighboring
development not so many years ago
guidance and policy changes in the
meantime can hardly justifiably block
the rebuilding of that house that was
previously on this site
as my granddaughter disapprovingly said
to me recently
seriously
can i just make a general point
that the use of the terms
substantial harm harm even less than
substantial harm pepper these reports
and it is heavy-duty wording in in this
context
it may be quoting from other sources
but i felt on reading it for myself that
it sets an unfair tone for the reader
tv news right now
is
is where those descriptions lie
and they set the wrong tone
where a resident is seeking to improve
their own home
so committee i conclude by repeating an
earlier point
please keep these applications in
perspective
sympathetically and carefully extending
a grade two house and building a house
where one used to be
thank you very much
thank you thank you councillor wetton um
any members wishing to open the
discussion to this item counselor
uh thank you um thank you to both
speakers um
very helpful and informative uh i
actually don't have a problem with um
extending or
the infill uh in principle uh i i do
have an issue with adding another
building onto it so that you're never
gonna win me around on that one
um but
preserving
such historic building um buildings
is
is
is vitally important um they are
probably it is prominent um
i've run past it when i can be bothered
going for a run it it does have the nice
feature to the area it does need to be
preserved my issue is with the plans
that have been submitted in this i agree
with the officers completely
there's a lot of work that needs to go
into this
and in order to preserve the building
and
from what's evident on the portal it
just isn't there so
i'm happy to support the officer's
recommendations to refuse this based on
the lack of detailed plans
thank you council chucking and
councillor minis
again i i can understand the want to
extend um and i can understand that um
the old cottages um whilst they are very
beautiful they um there's a difficulty
with this there's a space
inside however i think that the plans
and i think that the um
the officers have done a very good job
here and no no what the there's a lack
of detail and sadly with a listed
property we do need that detail
of how all the features will be
preserved and how
any extensions would be in keeping and
how it would actually
how it would
enhance the property so i'll be i'll be
seconding the proposal to
um
to go in favor of officer's
recommendation to refuse thank you
thank you um council chalking can i just
clarify were you proposing and is that
the case for all three applications yes
sir
and councilman
councilman is can you clarify he's
making a second seconding that motion on
all three applications yeah i i can
understand what you've
said
have said in the sense that
this seems quite a simple decision to me
in that
and we've seen paragraph 65 of the
report relating to application 105 247
um officers are stating that the plans
submitted just aren't detailed enough to
base a permission on when it comes to
changing um holistic building
and similarly that point is reinforced
in paragraph 28 of the report for 105
248 and when you look at the
recommendations for those two decisions
um
the lack of details and the plans is
clearly a reason for refusal
um in terms of
the third application
105249
and
i don't myself feel qualified to
contradict with the recommendation of
the heritage officers they're saying
that there's major harm and i i have to
accept that
um so but similarly to councillor chalk
in my view is i don't have in principle
and objection to um
a revision of a listed building it just
is that we need to have a sufficient
level of detail to feel confident that
um it's going to be carried out to an
excellent standard and i think we all
saw the the images projected on the
screen tonight and
personally and i'm i mean this
respectfully i just didn't think there
was a sufficient level of detail there
so i minded to support the motion that
has been proposed in a second did it
that any other members wish to speak
counselor hartley
thank you chair i i share a lot of the
comments you made i mean i i do think
these are fairly straightforward
decisions on these three applications i
think the um
i think i think the additions to the
cottage are unsympathetic um
i think the heritage offices assessment
is right that that's major harm to the
asset and moderate harm to the setting
um along with moderate harm to the
conservation area it does offend against
several of the policies in the
conservation area management plan
uh this the issue on the bat surveys
although i i
i understand what candidate said i went
and was saying that i'm sure we could
probably deal with that by condition but
it is absent at the moment
there's a clear reason to refuse on
heritage grounds um you know those those
harms outweigh the limited
um public benefits and the um i suppose
as far as the listed building
application goes
my reading of the report is that the
the listed building the asset should be
preserved and also enhanced that's
policy r1 which i know is not up to date
but the mppf
paragraph 497 says that the
development should make a positive
contribution to the local character and
distinctiveness
of the asset and i don't um i don't
think the editions do that
i think they're unsympathetic as i've
said and i suppose the key uh one of the
key points for me is that the
the house
it's a dwelling it's a viable dwelling
at the moment somebody's living in it it
might not be suitable for a family it
might not be suitable for everybody um
you know obviously we do we do see
listed buildings that are empty and
you know derelict and fall into a state
of disrepair and and there's a real
difficult judgment to be made there
around preserving and enhancing those
assets but
um in a way the applicant may have been
a victim of
their own diligent efforts to to
maintain and preserve the property and
that it's in a a very viable state at
the moment
um
i i probably have less objection to the
third application although i i do still
think uh i agree with the officer's
recommendation
it's a very large plot um
even for that area where there are lots
of large plots um
and a very you know very small dwelling
and in in a way that for me having
walked around the area and had a look
the the spaciousness of that plot
stands out in a way it may reflect the
historic character but it almost seems
out of place because of how spacious it
is so i i think in principle
it it could be subdivided but i think
the way in which it's it's proposed here
is is not appropriate because of the
the mass of the um the new dwelling the
converted garage uh the design of it i
agree is a
character the sighting of it is is
conspicuous as well
and the
the new access the new driveway the new
garage that that also
um creates i do think causes causes
significant harm to the setting so yeah
for all those reasons i agree with the
officer's recommendation to refuse all
three applications thank you
thank you and councillor welton
uh i agree with what a lot of what's
been said so far so i'll just um
just add one
particular concern i have with the
visual aspect of this um
uh this proposal and that i mean
you can really mainly view this from the
northwest
uh the northwest viewpoint from arbor
road from the from from the driveway and
at that point as it is at the moment you
get a
a
a lovely symmetrical view of of the two
cottages as were together and the
the principal concern is that the the
extension on that side breaks that
symmetry which is what gives the
building it's you know it's its
attractive appearance um and and the you
know the the appearance that that it's
held for so long and gives it its
conservation conservation value um
and so i i mean i i i think that's a uh
that's problematic i don't have so much
problem with the so much of a problem
with the extension at the back and i
know the previous extent they have had
substantial previous extensions approved
at the back i think
um looking back through some of the
previous uh documentation
um
it it it is difficult and it is you know
it is difficult for you know we don't
want
places like this to become a
museum but all but also the more that
the area around it gets developed with
large houses on you know on these
filling up these large plots almost the
important the importance of this
site is magnified and you know it is i
mean actually i have to say i really
appreciated actually having to go and
see it and you know i didn't know didn't
know about it before and you know
a pause on a walk past there to see
these lovely cottages in a decent
area of land
you know it
suddenly gave value to the to the
conservation area um and that has to
that has to be appreciated uh um uh and
so that also goes for the you know the
issues with the uh with the third
application for the extra the extra
development on the site um so as it as
it stands i have to i haven't got any
reason not to go with the cons the um
heritage officers report
and i agree with what everyone else has
been saying so far
thank you councillor and councillor
buntik
thank you chairman um
it's going to be difficult to agree with
many of the comments that have been
made so far i agree with
the previous speakers and whilst i feel
sympathetic towards the
applicant who i appreciate he may
have the best of intents i i don't agree
with with
what with with the plans as the vice
chairman pointed out were unsympathetic
for me also not only the side extensions
unsympathetically the link between the
roof structures i thought was
particularly unsympathetic but
um
and whilst i i would agree with other
speakers that it would be possible
given a different design uh to maybe
extend it at some point i i can't agree
when you go through the report and then
you go through the uh reasons for
refusal you say well okay which ones of
these reasons for refusal can i
dismiss and which ones can i say and are
not accurate and how can i make an
argument against each of those those
points it's it's not possible for me to
do that um we've heard from uh mr
griffiths and councillor wetton this
evening both of whom have made valiant
attempts uh
uh to
to defend this these proposals uh but
sometimes variance isn't sufficient
um and so i can't whilst i accepted any
i accept council lessons point yeah
the film wasn't supposed to be paused
we're not supposed to freeze it aspect
that's not what we're proposing here
we're not saying no to any future
changes on this site at all uh no to any
future development uh but not this
development and maybe if a future
application is brought forward that's
done in a different manner then maybe uh
it will be possible to support it but
obviously we'd have to wait and see
uh but as it stands at the moment um i i
i i wouldn't be able to to vote against
officer recommendation maybe one of the
few areas that i would disagree with the
vice chairman on um and it is a
more minor disagreement this is his
argument over the subdivision whilst i
accept yes vice chairman this is a
substantial plot that this is sitting in
if you were to subdivide it presumably
you would be looking to do so on a sort
of 50 50 basis now you could maybe say
well if a plot would say 25 smaller than
it is at the moment then that might look
more balanced and more sort of rounded
but then again that would not be
sufficient to then put another property
on something whilst yes you could lose
some of the land uh surrounding this
property and not cause harm i don't
think you could lose enough of the land
around this property to
uh reasonably locate a additional
dwelling so
whilst i feel sympathetic to the
applicant i do agree with the officers
in relation to these three
uh
these three applications have already
proposed and seconded that we refuse all
three and i will uh
be voting in that way as well thank you
chairman
thank you councillor punting any other
members wishing to contribute to the
discussion
no no okay
um has been proposed and seconded that
permission for each of these
applications be refused in line with
officer recommendation
um we'll take a vote on application 105
247 first
and if members supporting the motion to
refuse permission can indicate now
please
okay thank you
and we'll now turn to application 105
248
and if members who support the motion to
refuse permission in line with officer
recommendation can indicate now please
okay thank you and lastly we'll turn to
application
105249 again it's been proposed and
seconded that permission be refused in
line with officer recommendation
members in support of that motion can
indicate now please
okay thank you and those three
applications are refused and thank you
everybody
um we're now turning to application 105
905 world of pets which is in temporary
information of which can be found on
page 211 of the committee report
you
you
okay um application 105 905 world of
pets in simply
um
before we hear from speakers to this
application we are going to receive an
introduction outlining plans from ms
lowes
thank you
this application relates to the site at
the world of pets and world of water
site on thorley lane in timperley
the application relates to a proposed
residential development of the form of
world of pets and world of water sites
located on the west side of thorly lane
in templeley the application has been
submitted an outline for 116 dwellings
of which 45 is to be affordable housing
with consent sort for access only
at this stage and all other matters
reserved
the existing vehicular access from
thorley lane um here
and the second vehicle access is from
wood lane here and both of these are
existing and would be retained
and they've been um
sorry
they've been historically used and will
be retained in this current proposal
parameters plans have been submitted and
with the proposal that detail access and
heights and the land uses to be proposed
and the
parameters plan one shown on the plan
now shows the two access points off wood
lane and thorley lane all shows shows
the constraints um of the template brook
um of which an eight meter easement is
required
and
a separation distance and to residential
properties um on um wood lane
the second parameters plan shows and the
areas and heights to be
utilized for residential development
around the periphery of the site and
two-story buildings are proposed and in
the centre of the site in two to three
storeys
um on the southern boundary and adjacent
to the brook would be an area of
extensive iron landscaping and
boundary treatment
boundary planting would be proposed
along the
boundaries
the application site is located in the
green belt and national and local
planning policy dictates that
construction of new buildings in the
greenbelt should be regarded as
inappropriate development which is by
definition harmful to the greenbelt
the mppf goes on to say that
inappropriate developments should not be
approved except in very special
circumstances
the applicant has detailed a number of
very special circumstances
which they contend outweigh the harm to
green belts by reason of
inappropriateness
these very special circumstances
reference the inclusion of the
application site within the draft places
for everyone plan
and the allocation of temporally wedge
the typically wedge allocation
would include the application site and
other identified areas of land being
released from the greenbelt the plan has
recently been submitted for examination
in public
and given the stage at which the plan is
at in the plan making process limited
weight is afforded to the plan in the
determination of this application
on the screen now you see an indicative
site layout which has been submitted to
demonstrate the quantum of development
which could be achieved and it
illustrates just one way in which the
site could be developed as layout is not
sought for approval at this stage
it is considered that the proposed
development would have a greater impact
on the openness of the greenbelt than
the existing buildings on the site and
would also conflict with the one of the
five purposes of greenbelt in that it
would represent encroachment into the
countryside
none of the arguments advanced by the
applicant including the limited weight
afforded to the places for everyone plan
are considered to constitute very
special circumstances individually or
cumulatively which might outweigh the
identified harm to greenbelt by reason
of inappropriateness harm to openness
and encroachment into the countryside
the development is considered to be in
an unsustainable location and is
contrary to the current development plan
in relation to the spatial strategy set
out in the core strategy
the scheme would provide policy
compliant level of affordable housing
and contributions towards education
which are weighed in the balance
all other matters have been assessed
including hiring matters and the
appropriateness of the proposed vehicle
access and are considered acceptable i
am subject to appropriate mitigation
should up should an application be
granted
however notwithstanding this but the
proposal fails to accord with policies
l1 and r4 of the core strategy along
with the mppf which directs
refusal of this application in respect
to the green belt the application is
therefore recommended for approval thank
you
thank you ms loews
we have received a registration from
carly rushden who'd like to speak
against the application i understand
she's provided a statement which will be
read out by councillor new gwash thank
you
thank you can i just just check that
that was for refusal not approval
so yes
i think you said
she did say approval i just want to
check
please did i
yes
sorry
recommended for refusal apologies thank
you
okay
thank you councillors tonight i'm going
to be reading the words of a resident uh
verbatim so apologies
if i run out of time um we should not be
building on greenbelt land at present
this site is classified as greenbelt and
should be assessed as such
the site is proposed for removal from
greenbelt under the pfe however this has
not received full approval from the
secretary of state making an early
decision to accept this planning
application would prejudice the decision
of the
pfe proposal
the proposed development would create
encroachment into the countryside and i
would remind everyone that a proposal
next to this site 130 wood lane planning
reference 83480
was refused by the council and upheld at
appeal as it fell outside these
greenbelt regulations
the design and appearance of the
proposal is not in keeping with the area
116 development at dwellings on this
development is far too big and
overbearing
um three amended from four-story houses
including the plans are out of character
with the neighboring houses the proposal
of 23 properties were rejected for
having too big an impact on this very
site 116 will certainly have a more
detrimental impact it will have a
devastating impact of confiscate
converse
conservation and wildlife the southern
part of this site is allocated as a
wildlife corridor within the revised
unitary development plan whilst the
plans intend to reinstate one the damage
to wildlife and habitats
during development is too great a net
less of loss of biodiversity confirmed
by the gm ecology unit the world the
water site contains many ponds overgrown
areas rifewood wildlife and habitats
which will be destroyed residents on
green lane backing onto the site and
myself downstream have witnessed bats
owls frogs foxes hedges and newts all
within the gardens and within the
proposed site the site contains a
floodplain and this development poses
further risk of uh to the area the site
is located within a critical drainage
area as specified within a trafford's
council strategic flood risk assessment
removal of mature trees on the site
which are soaking up massive amounts of
water will have a detrimental
whilst there are plans to plant new
trees it will take years for them to
reach the level of absorption the
current existing mature trees do a
mature oak can absorb 50 or more gallons
of water in a day
the the resident lives 500 meters
downstream from the site and during the
periods of heavy rain over the last the
last 16 months have witnessed the brook
rise five foot and caused flooding uh in
both king george fifth pool and um
ultringham golf course
concerns over highway safety 116 new
dwellings will generate additional
traffic on the road around the site
including woodland greenland thorley
lane which already congested especially
around peak times
safety and walking for children um to
the cloverley school and watching
college must be considered um and whilst
the main entrance of the site will
remain on thorley lane there'll be
secondary entrances i'll finish the
second
it's not suited to large vehicles for
access
near narrow nip on narrows pavements
near schools and immunities to school in
particular local schools are already
heavily over subscribed the addition of
160 more homes largely aimed at families
without the addition of these schools
places will cause havoc to an already
challenged school admission situation
thank you members for listening and i
request the counselors support officers
considered recommendations and refuse
this application
thank you councillor nicosham also
registered to speak against this
application is counselor dylan booked um
are you okay go into the microphone at
that table there counselor then you've
got five minutes to speak if you do one
overtime i'll just like that's that you
wrap up your contribution thank you
thank you cher
most of the issues have been
comprehensive covered in the report so i
shall keep it fairly brief
i would like to
commend the planning office for the
clear until report which has
taken account of the essence of the nppf
in continuing to protect this site
and its justified recommendation for
refusal this application
and certainly any generation of
construction jobs that have been
mentioned temporary as they would be is
unlikely to benefit the demographics of
the local area just to tell us
that point a the local community in its
response to the application has
demonstrated unequivocally the need to
defend this fairly open area of
greenbelt which is considered a
cherished landmark in itself
it provides physical and mental benefits
to hulk residents as well as being a
wildlife sanctuary for increasingly
endangered species
its very geographical nature also
provides a natural drainage path to
timperley brook
so i would
support the refusal for this uh
application thank you very much
thank you councillor um
have a speaker registered to speak in
favor of this application james
nicholson
hi mr nicholson thanks for joining us um
you've got three minutes to speak if you
do one overtime i'll just politely ask
that you used to wrap up your
contribution thank you
hi good evening councillors um tonight
you have the opportunity to approve the
planning application for up to 116 new
homes in timperley of which 52 will be
affordable 45
traffic council does not have a
five-year housing land supply and it's
not had one for almost a decade and we
believe the current supply is less than
three years i therefore ask you to
contemplate whether you'll stick with an
outdated greenbelt policy that will soon
be changed as a result of places for
everyone or be on the side of the 40 of
trafford residents who stated they have
been personally affected by the housing
shortage during our public consultation
the submission marks the culmination of
nearly three years of positive
collaboration with trafford council the
council of londoners have worked hard to
finalize trafford's best plan for the
future of this area a plan that's been
signed off by trafford's leadership
greater manchester's combined authority
and is now sitting with the planning
inspector for examination
the site's been allocated for
residential development as per this
application in the places for everyone
development plan and your fellow
councillors voted last year to approve
this document and this is site number
one of phase one of delivery of new
homes in trafford if approved it's
likely that works will commence early
next year and by approving the
application now this site will be ready
to provide of new affordable homes
following an expected approval of places
for everyone planned approving the
application today will ensure that
delivery of new homes will commence in
parallel with this process
the perceived home to the green belt is
the sole reason for refusal of this
application put forward by the officers
however we're proposing to regenerate a
former garden center made up of hard
standing concrete and derelict
greenhouses into affordable new homes
for local families this is not a
beautiful field untouched by development
and indeed 50 of the site is classified
as previously developed brownfield land
in addition there's a legally sound
justification for committee to vote to
approve this application the qc advice
is clear very special circumstances do
exist for the application to be granted
approval this advice is based on the
ongoing housing land shortfall and the
chronic undersupply of housing generally
in trafford along with the following
benefits 45 on-site affordable housing
low zero carbon homes a new play area
wildlife corridor and accessible open
space the use of sustainable urban
drainage new pedestrian and cycle routes
around a half a million pound of sill
payment plus additional 106
contributions and economic benefits to
supporting local employment
along with new electric vehicle charging
points for public use tonight i ask you
to put aside concerns about harm to an
area of greenbelt that your council has
already voted to reallocate for
development i ask you to weigh up the
merits of refusal versus the cost of the
clear legal opinion that we've shared
with your officers i ask you to
interrogate the conclusion your officers
have come to and i ask you to vote for
new affordable homes asking you to
approve our outline planning application
as a final thought you could vote to
approve tonight safe in the knowledge
that your decision will be reviewed by
the secretary of state which the
ultimate decision will be wrestling with
his department
thanks very much for your time i
appreciate all the efforts have gone
into this
thank you mr nicholson thanks for
joining us this evening i'm councillor
minis
thank you chair
this development does reside within the
great greenbelt
and although parts of it have been you
know it has
it does have
um has a building on there and part of
it is therefore brownfield site it is in
the greenbelt and even if
people weren't concerned about the
technicality of what it's called because
it's about to be released which i don't
agree with but that's different matter
there are there are issues with the
conservation of
of beings that aren't human
but we all need to have consideration
for
so
on grounds of the basically the
there's a similar issue i have with a
building on the green belt in general
what is currently greenbelt
where you have where you have lots of
species you have
we also have even to humans as it were
the lack of infrastructure thorley lane
and
park road and other roads that that link
to this area
simply cannot take the traffic i live
just off park road it can't take the
traffic
we need all we you know when we're going
to if we're going to build a load of
houses we need to think about the
infrastructure and the roads and places
near it it's simply not not what should
be done and and in terms of the places
for everyone i don't agree with that one
either but there we go
um i i propose that we
we support officer recommendation and
refuse this thank you very much
thank you councillor i'm councillor
bunting
thank you chairman um i'm going to agree
with councillor minis on this one uh and
i'm more than happy to second proposal
that she just made
i've actually
done as was suggested by the applicant
i've been through this application and
i've reviewed the positives and the
negatives i've looked to see could we
justify a
an overturning essentially of agreement
on grounds that there are such special
circumstances surrounding this
application
that justifies uh development within the
green belt and at the end of that
process i've come to the conclusion that
the answer is no
uh i do not believe that there are
anywhere near
not even close to being sufficient
circumstances
uh necessary to uh developing the green
belt the presumption is against
unless there are exceptional
circumstances there are no such
exceptional model no no there are
nowhere near enough exceptional
circumstances to justify uh the
development within the green belt and so
on that basis jeb and i shall be voting
in line with officer recommendation
thank you chairman
thank you and counselor winston
uh thank you chad i'm really torn on
this one um i have to live there there
i was quite i used to drive up falling
on my way home i was quite surprised to
find that thought delay was in the
greenbelt
because it's
the sides
it's
light industrial it's retail there's
lots of housing estates around there
the reason i am torn
is because if pfe is um accepted by the
secretary of state then i see no reason
why it will will not be accepted by the
secretary of state
then this area will not be in the green
belt anymore and it will perform more
parts of simply wedge and if we turn
this down today it is going to come back
again in six or 12 months maybe in a
different fall
the reason and that's what i'm really
talking about in my my pragmatic head
says this is going to get approved at
some point we should do it tonight
but there's a very clear recommendation
in the report that says this contravenes
the
legislation now exists because it is in
the green belt
the
developer made reference to a very clear
legal opinion which had been shared with
the
uh with the planning team is it
appropriate to share that very clear
legal opinion he maintains with
this committee tonight
maybe to clarify matters
thank you sure i think we can
the clear legal opinion said that you
could grant it
um and
you can grant it if you think there are
very special circumstances it went it
went it said
that
there were
but actually a matter of planning
judgment is not for barrister it's for
him
it's for officers we got our own council
advice which said that it hurt on that
point and that um pfe was would and the
weight to be given to in the very
special circumstances it's a battle for
the decision maker
so but
that that is it in summary if if members
are interested in it it's on the
planning file and we can we we we can
share that if the uh
yeah if the applicant is willing
[Music]
i mean you're quite right councilman
stanley if pfe progresses as
proposed this site will come back and
officer's recommendation will be
different
thank you
thank you i'm councillor partly
yeah i understand cancer when stanley's
dilemma actually when i when i looked at
the
uh the application started to read the
report i
i didn't really understand the
recommendation because
you know if if the place where everyone
does go through this will be released
and this and this will be this will be
developed but having read the report
more i do think this is quite
straightforward actually it is
greenbeltland it's protected asset
i don't think any of the very special
circumstances are made out for
developing that that green belt that
that position may change in the future
if places for everyone is is approved
but
i think um
and you know the housing supplier
shortage i don't think comes anywhere
near to being a very special
circumstance that's an improving
position as well
um
and and the positives which i noted 45
affordable housing the
play area the um
low carbon
uh
aspirations that you know the
contributions
they're they're all positives but
they're all expected positives that's
that's what you'd expect um by a
planning policy if we were to approve it
so
they aren't um you know they aren't
special positives they are as you'd
expect and and they mitigate the impact
of of the development so
um i i don't think they make um make a
huge amount of difference
i suppose the difference is when if
places for everyone and i i voted for
places for everyone uh and i and i would
like to see it happen
so if that does go ahead and the land is
released from greenbelt for development
that that will be done in a coordinated
way
and the impact of the whole development
and
infrastructure that would need to be
provided and funded will will be
considered
the problem with approving just this
scheme
you know which i don't think we can do
but i that would then develop in a
different way and you can see that in
the report there's quite a lot of
commentary about
how the developer would have to mitigate
this particular development but in quite
a localized way all the talk about the
traffic island etc
and i don't think
i don't think that is at all advisable
um because of the
scale of the development that is
proposed on temporary wedge that needs
to be
done in a coordinated way i think and
i know i know each application is kind
of considered on its merits and doesn't
set a precedent but
it would defeat the whole purpose of of
pfe if we had a number of applications
coming forward before it was approved
seeking approval to build on greenbelt
on the basis that that might happen in
the future you'd then have a you know a
patchwork of
um of developments that that would be
done in an uncoordinated way and i think
will be will be a lot worse for
residents so yeah i think it's fairly
clear that
we should support the recommendation for
refusal thank you thank you
councillor welton
uh yeah i very much agree with what
councillor hartley has just said so i'm
not going to add a huge amount more in
its current form this is of
unsustainable car centric developments
it's not a you know it's it's a lot of
extra properties to be put in the public
transport links are a terrible it may
have it may get some you know on in on
the site itself they may put in some
cycling infrastructure but that doesn't
help you connect up to everything else
the places for everything
plan if you know when the if the timpy
wedge gets um gets built on then
these kind of issues it may become
a sustainable site because there's lots
of public transport development and that
kind of thing
that's an if we don't know
government policy may change in
in the meantime so i don't mean so i
think we can afford to wait on this one
you know i i i think we can afford the
council can afford to be tactical on
this one it has a perfectly good
planning reason to refuse it and i think
you know
it's absolutely right to
suggest that we refuse it um on on the
green belt grounds even if it is
tactical
um you know and and wanting to move it
into a in into the future um
so i i accept that point and i shall be
supporting refusal
thank you
councillor chalking please
uh thank you i agree with everything
that's actually been said i just i i've
re-emphasized council heart at this
point about having joined up thinking in
the future um
that junction that road can be a
nightmare even now at peak times adding
another 1600 homes on further down clay
lane is just gonna
cause immeasurable problems
without joint of thinking so
i just bear that in mind for everybody
um and just to become something else and
said just to further develop it the
there's a very very poor cycle route
down 40 line um it's it's the old
painted scheme and it was i was
disappointed to see there was no
reference to something like that in the
report i current i think
murder strip council wasn't saying um
but my disappointment was that there was
no uh suggestion that that could be
improved
if further you know when the reserve
matters are being considered so
i think we should just
may want to think about that in the
future
for me there were 116 homes on this site
notwithstanding the points about it
being greenbelt right now 116 homes is
just too much
it's too too many houses too many
vehicles
we've got too many other pressures which
the report rightly highlights
in the area
um it's not the right time to approve
something like this in principle i have
no objection with housing being put here
um you know i should places for everyone
be developed signed off
no no objection but i'm not on this
scale
for me
thank you
thank you councillor um
do you just want to reflect on the fact
that i think this site could be brought
forward for development the applicant
and speaking before highlighted that a
huge chunk of the plot
would really see redevelopment you know
the the old garden center the bit that's
concreted over it makes sense i think
i'd also just like to acknowledge that
the applicant has clearly put a lot of
work into
thinking about how this site can be
developed i thought the
looked nice when i saw them on screen
and i think it's really laudable um that
they were prepared not to play um sort
of silly games that we sometimes see
from developers when it comes to
affordable housing so um
i thank them for that and personally
if i am still on a future planning
committee once pfe has been adopted if
it is in full um i i would most probably
be quite happy to support this
application and so for me it's a sort of
technical refusal more so than anything
um
which uh a technical refusal on on the
basis of uh the recommendation from the
officers which um relating to the green
belt
um
so it's been proposed by council
minister that
the application be refused permission
for development i don't do that as any
member seconded
counselor one thing
thank you um are there any members who
wish to make any contribution before me
to the vote
no one's indicating okay um
so it's been moved in second did the
permission be refused for this
development in line with office of
recommendation
members in supported that
motion can indicate now please
okay
thank you everybody so that application
is refused
um
we are now past
the
time for committee to continue we
haven't finished all of the um items for
permission to for development i think we
did already have a
an adjourned meeting date confirmed just
yes
uh yes uh
officers and the chairman did anticipate
we might be in this position so we will
reconvene at hopper six on monday
um for the avoidance start monday the
14th of march thank you
members
okay
thank you
and that will pick up agenda item seven
at that point so with that uh we'll
close this meeting thank you
sorry
we're in this room yeah thank you
okay thank you everybody
you